Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Musik So Tom Holland, that was a national anthem. And 10 points to you if you can guess which anthem it was. I thought you just tuned into Radio 3. It sounded kind of like generic, slightly boring Radio 3 music. I think that's very harsh. That is one of my favourite national anthems. It's the national anthem of the German Democratic Republic, East Germany as was. A country that, Tom, you and I would have taken completely for granted.
感谢收听《历史的 rest》。如果您想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告收听、提前解锁系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。音乐。所以，汤姆·霍兰，刚才那是一首国歌。如果你能猜出那是哪首歌，给你加10分。我还以为你刚才调到了BBC广播三台。听起来有点像那种大众化的、稍微有点无聊的广播三台音乐。我觉得这评价太苛刻了。那可是我最喜欢的国歌之一。那是德意志民主共和国的国歌，也就是过去的东德。汤姆，对于这个国家，你我都曾经觉得它的存在是理所当然的。
When we were growing up, yes. When we were growing up as a fixture on the sporting map. I mean, think about it, the Olympics. But also it was a a sort of avatar wasn't it in the west but also um a fixture in spy novels yeah exactly it was a sort of shorthand for the iron curtain the iron curtain warsaw pact all that kind of stuff yeah but now completely gone and therefore one with nineveh and tyre and therefore very much um a suitable subject for a history podcast. And fortunately, Dominic, we have just the person with us, don't we, who can tell us about East Germany. We do. Long-term listeners to the rest of this issue will remember when we did Bismarck and Bismarck's Reich, the Second German Reich. And we had a wonderful guest called Katja Hoyer, who it turns out, Tom, is, or at least was was an East German. So Katja, not were you an East
当我们长大的时候，是的。当我们长大地看到它作为体育版图上的一个固定存在。我是说，想想看，奥运会。但它也是西方世界的一种某种化身，同时也是间谍小说里的常见设定——没错，它简直是铁幕、铁幕、华沙条约组织之类事物的代名词。是的，但现在它彻底消失了，因此它和尼尼微与推罗一样成为了历史，非常适合作为历史播客的题材。幸运的是，多米尼克，我们身边正好有一位专家，可以跟我们讲讲东德的故事，对吧？确实如此。长期收听《历史的 rest》的听迷们会记得，当我们讲俾斯麦和俾斯麦的帝国、德意志第二帝国时，我们曾请到过一位非常棒的嘉宾，名叫卡佳·霍耶（Katja Hoyer）。汤姆，原来她就是、或者说至少曾经是一个东德人。所以，卡佳，你不但是个东德
German, but you have now written the book on East Germany, which is Beyond the Wall, East Germany, 1949 to 1990. So this book's a bit different from your last one. This is a bit more of a personal book, I guess, because it's about your own upbringing actually features at the end of the book, doesn't it? Well, I did write it as a historian rather than as a personal history of the GDR, but you can't ever quite sort of get away from your own personal background as a historian, I feel. So I felt obviously I had to be A, honest about the fact that I am from East Germany and that this is going to colour my perspective of the country to some extent. And B, I didn't see why I shouldn't bring in my own kind of perspective, my own family as part of the group of people that I
人，你现在还写了一本关于东德的专著，书名叫《墙的另一边：东德，1949年至1990年》（Beyond the Wall, East Germany, 1949 to 1990）。所以这本书跟你上一本有点不一样。这似乎是一本更具个人色彩的书，因为你的成长经历实际上也出现在了书的结尾，对吧？嗯，我写这本书时是以历史学家的身份，而不是作为德意志民主共和国（GDR）的个人历史来写的，但作为一名历史学家，你永远无法完全摆脱自己的个人背景，我是这么觉得的。所以我觉得自己显然必须做到两点：第一，坦诚地承认我来自东德，这在某种程度上会影响我对这个国家的看法；第二，我没有理由不把自己的视角、自己的家族作为我所引入的那群人的一部分，
bring into the mix in terms of explaining what the country was like from the perspective of those who lived there. So Katja, in your book, you have a very striking formulation. You say that the GDR, so East Germany, was unique among the Eastern Bloc nations in that its very existence was never assured. So the other Warsaw Pact nations, Poland, Romania, Bulgaria, whatever, I mean, these are kind of nation states. But the whole thing about East Germany is that actually, it's carved out of the Third Reich. And the question of whether it should ever have existed in the first place is hugely debated, not just by Germans, not just by people in the West, but also, I learned, from Stalin. Its origins lie in that kind of massive,
以此来从那些生活在那里的人的视角解释这个国家曾经是什么样子。卡佳，在你的书中，有一个非常引人注目的观点。你说民主德国，也就是东德，在东方集团国家中是独一无二的，因为它的生存从一开始就从未得到过保证。所以其他的华沙条约组织成员国，波兰、罗马尼亚、保加利亚等等，我的意思是，这些都是某种意义上的民族国家。但东德的整个问题在于，实际上它是从第三帝国中被分割出来的。而且它一开始究竟应不应该存在，这个问题的争论极其激烈，不仅是德国人、西方人这样争论，据我了解，斯大林也是如此。它的根源在于那种在20世纪席卷德国的巨大、
massive catastrophe that overwhelms Germany over the course of the 20th century. How far back do the roots of East Germany run? Back to the Third Reich? Back to the Russian Revolution? How far back does it go? Well, they certainly, when later they rediscovered Prussia and Martin Luther and other things, they thought it went way further back. But of course, that was a means of legitimising the fact that there was this fairly artificial line drawn in the middle of Germany after the Second World War, which is entirely a political decision, a decision based on where troops were at the time when they occupied Germany. And it's certainly not a kind of natural line that evolved over centuries, as you find with many other countries.
巨大灾难。东德的根源可以追溯到多远？追溯到第三帝国？还是追溯到俄国革命？它可以追溯到多久以前？嗯，当他们后来重新发现普鲁士、马丁·路德和其他事物时，他们当然认为它的根源可以追溯到更久远的过去。但当然，这只是一种手段，用来使二战后在德国中部划出的这条相当人工的、完全是基于当时占领德国的军队所在地的政治决定合法的工具。它绝对不是像你在许多其他国家所看到的那样，经过几个世纪自然演变而成的自然分界线。
And because of that, you basically have a country, one nation now split into two, which will naturally try and revert to some form of unity, national unity. And on the other side, you've got Stalin sitting there, not really keen on the idea that East Germany is part of this realm that he has to look after, because it doesn't, in his view, fit into this kind of natural sphere of influence that Russia deems Eastern Europe to be, the Slavic people effectively. So Germany is always going to be, from a Russian perspective, part of the Western world, part of Western Europe, and therefore not necessarily a natural part of the Soviet empire or, more widely speaking, the Russian influence in Europe. GDR certainly, where the Soviets are basically thinking, can we trade this in? Is it really worth having? And so the GDR government is constantly going to look east and west for justification for its own existence. I was amazed to learn that. I had no idea
正因为如此，你基本上得到了这样一个国家：一个原本统一的国家现在分裂成了两个，它自然会试图恢复某种形式的统一，即国家统一。而在另一边，斯大林坐在那里，其实并不太乐意看到东德成为他必须照看领土的一部分，因为在他看来，这并不符合俄罗斯视东欧为理所当然的自然势力范围，也就是斯拉夫人的势力范围。因此，从俄罗斯的角度来看，德国将永远是西方世界的一部分，是西欧的一部分，因此不一定是苏联帝国或更广泛意义上的俄罗斯在欧洲影响力的自然组成部分。民主德国肯定让苏联人觉得：我们能把它交易出去吗？它真的值得拥有吗？因此，民主德国政府将不断地向东西方寻找为其自身存在合理性的证明。我很惊讶地了解到这一点。我完全不知道
that Stalin was so reluctant and that essentially the drive for it comes from German communists. Is that right? And principally, German communists who had fled the Nazis and gone to Russia and survived all the various purges, which claimed the lives of many German communists and who had been kind of battle hardened and forged into becoming the most loyal of the loyal as far as Stalin was concerned. And so they were able to essentially kind of pressure him and say, you know, we're here for you. Yeah. I mean, that is an interesting fact that is often forgotten when you think, you know, out of the Communist Party's leadership that go to Russia to flee Hitler's regime, at the end of the war, only two of them are left standing, literally. And that's Willem Pieck, who will become the first and only president of the GDR,
斯大林竟然如此不情愿，而推动这一进程的主要是德国共产党人。是这样吗？主要是那些逃离纳粹、前往俄罗斯并幸存下来、经历过各种清洗的德国共产党人。这些清洗夺去了许多德国共产党员的生命，而活下来的人经过战火的淬炼，在斯大林看来，成为了忠诚者中最忠诚的人。因此，他们能够基本上向斯大林施压，说：“你知道的，我们是为你而来的。”是的。我的意思是，这是一个有趣的事实，当我们想到逃离希特勒政权前往俄罗斯的共产党领导层时，往往会忘记这一点：战争结束时，真正站到最后的总共只有两个人。那就是威廉·皮克（Willem Pieck），他将成为民主德国的第一任也是最后一任总统，
and Walter Albrecht, who will sort of lead its fortune for the first two decades. And that's not a coincidence that those people survived while others didn't. And at the same time, you now have a situation, I mean, the fact that Stalin is reluctant is my opinion, and many other historians think the same way. There are historians, I should point out, who don't think this and who think that Stalin was always keen to hold on to East Germany and go as far into Western Europe as he could. He's notoriously hard to pin down because he's so waffly in the way that he expresses his own opinion, so reluctant to have them kind of written in documents that it's really hard to sort of grasp what he actually wants from one moment to the next. But there is this like odd admiration for Germany as well,
还有沃尔特·阿尔布雷希特（Walter Albrecht，注：应为沃尔特·乌尔布里希特 Walter Ulbricht），他在前二十年里将左右民主德国的命运。这些人能够幸存而其他人没有，这绝非巧合。与此同时，你现在面临这样一种情况——斯大林很不情愿，这是我的观点，许多其他历史学家也这么认为。我应该指出，也有一些历史学家不这么认为，他们认为斯大林一直渴望抓住东德不放，并尽可能深入地向西欧推进。斯大林出了名的难以捉摸，因为他在表达自己观点时总是模棱两可，极不愿意将自己的观点写进文件中，所以你很难弄清楚他到底在不同的阶段想要什么。但在背景中，确实存在着一种对德国的奇特崇拜，
that he's got kind of like a love-hate relationship with Germany. And the idea that he should look after something that he, to some extent, views as a kind of another great European power, it's not to be a satellite state as such, is also there in the background, I think. And there are people in this inner circle. You've got people like Beria, for example, the notorious sort of chief of the secret police, who doesn't view the GDR as a proper country. He says that quite openly and says, you know, what is this thing?
也就是说，他对德国有一种爱恨交织的关系。我认为，在背景中也存在这样一种想法：他应该照顾这样一个在某种程度上被他视为另一个伟大的欧洲列强的国家——它本身并不打算成为一个卫星国。在核心圈子里也有这样的人。比如有贝利亚（Beria）这样的人，他是臭名昭著的秘密警察头子，不把民主德国当成一个真正的国家。他很公开地这么说，并表示：“你知道，这到底是个什么东西？
If we're not looking after it, it would just crumble into West Germany. And there are constant considerations, all the trouble, you know, all the troops that have to go into it at the front lines of the Cold War, the awkward situation in Berlin with the open city that's split into two. All of that is there on people's minds. And the question is always there, should we not just give in and leave it? To go back to the leaders. So you mentioned Wilhelm Pieck and Walter Ulbricht, who are the sort of founding fathers
如果我们不去照看它，它就会直接崩溃并融入西国。”人们脑子里总是有各种各样的顾虑：所有的麻烦、所有必须投入冷战前线的军队、柏林那个被一分为二的开放城市的尴尬局势。所有这些都在人们的脑海中盘旋。问题始终是：我们难道不该直接妥协并离开吗？回到领导人身上。所以你提到了威廉·皮克和沃尔特·乌尔布里希特，他们是民主德国的某种意义上的国父，
of the GDR, and they had been in Moscow in the 1930s. How much do you think the tone of political life in East Germany was shaped by the fact that they've been in the purges, in the terror. Do you think that hung over the country right through to the very end? How much was that sense of mistrust and the lives of others, the tone of East German life that we're familiar with in the West because that's become our stereotype of East Germany, how much was that dictated by the fact that they had been there in the 30s? Or would that have been there anyway? Because Katja, you give the amazing statistic that
他们在20世纪30年代曾在莫斯科。你认为东德政治生活的基调在多大程度上受到他们曾经历过清洗和恐怖的影响？你认为这股阴影是否一直笼罩着这个国家直到最后？那种不信任感和他人的生活——我们在西方所熟悉的东德生活基调（因为那已经成了我们对东德的刻板印象）——在多大程度上是由他们曾在30年代经历过这些而决定的？还是说这种基调无论如何都会存在？因为卡佳，你给出了一个惊人的统计数据：
only a quarter of German exiles in Russia survived the purges. Yeah, it's really quite amazing when you think about this and the amount of terror and the psychological impact that this would have had on these people as individuals. I think it's hard to underestimate. When you think further back as well, they had these hefty street battles on the streets of the Weimar Republic. And then Hitler obviously drives that to a whole new level. And suddenly, they run away from all of that. And they end up in a situation that's even more deadly. I mean, if you're German and you're in Russia during the Second World War, it's more likely that you will be dead at the end of the war than alive. And coming out of all of that, a lifetime's worth of persecution, if you will, or looking over your shoulder for people that have got it in for you, has got to
只有四分之一在俄国的德国流亡者在清洗中幸存下来。是的，当你想到这一点时，会觉得非常震撼，这种恐怖以及对这些个人所造成的心理影响是很难被低估的。如果你往回看，他们曾在魏玛共和国的街头上进行过激烈的街头巷战。然后希特勒显然把这种冲突推向了一个全新的高度。突然之间，他们逃离了这一切，却最终陷入了一个更加致命的境地。我的意思是，如果你是一个德国人，在二战期间身处俄国，那么战争结束时你死去的可能性要远远大于活下来的可能性。经历这一切——可以说是贯穿一生的迫害，或者随时提防着那些想整你的人——必然会对你的行事方式、对你建立国家的方式产生某种政治影响，我认为。
have some sort of political impact, I think, on the way that you act, that you set up a state. And this goes for people like Eric Mirger, who, for instance, fought in the, was deployed in the Spanish Civil War as a kind of underground terrorist, if you will. So, again, constantly looking over his shoulder for enemies. And Eric Milker is the guy who goes on to found the Stasi, the secret police. Yeah, absolutely. And with that kind of Russia as a role model in mind. So he openly calls his staff, for instance, the Chekists after the Russian secret police, but also with his experiences in Russia in mind, where he actually witnessed some of the show trials that were going on under Stalin.
这同样适用于像埃里希·梅尔克（Eric Mirger，注：应为 Erich Mielke）这样的人，他曾在西班牙内战中作为某种地下恐怖分子作战。所以，他同样一直在提防着敌人。而埃里希·梅尔克正是后来创立国家安全部（史塔西，Stasi，即秘密警察）的那个人。是的，绝对如此，并且是以俄罗斯为榜样。因此，他公开把自己的手下称为“契卡分子”（Chekists，模仿俄罗斯秘密警察），而且这也是基于他在俄罗斯的经历，他甚至亲眼目睹了斯大林统治下的几场作秀审判。
So in many ways, I think, you know, people don't come out of nowhere in 1949 with no background. And that, I think, plays into the early years, certainly of the GDR. And because the personnel doesn't really change. I mean, Erich Muehlke is there to the very end in 1989. You've also got Eric Honecker, who leads the GDR for the second half of its existence, who also sat in Nazi prisons for years on end. So in many ways, you know,
所以在很多方面，我认为人们并不是在1949年凭空出现、毫无背景的。我认为这在很大程度上影响了民主德国的早期历史。而且因为人事并没有真正的变动——我的意思是，埃里希·梅尔克一直在那里直到1989年的最后时刻。还有埃里希·昂纳克（Eric Honecker，即埃里希·昂纳克 Erich Honecker），他在民主德国存在的后半段领导了国家，他也在纳粹监狱里关押了多年。所以在很多方面，
you don't get a fresh generation of people that have grown up during kind of a relatively peaceful era with less psychological baggage. So just on the foundation of the GDR, I mean, Tom was asking that question about Stalin, which I also found fascinating because I had always imagined that the decision to create a separate state was largely inspired from Moscow rather than from within the future East German state itself. So is there a future? Is there an alternative universe in which there is a united Germany going into the 1950s? Or do you think that the way that the Second World War ended,
你并没有迎来一个在相对和平的时代长大、心理负担较轻的新一代人。那么，关于民主德国的建立，汤姆刚才问了关于斯大林的问题，我也觉得非常引人入胜，因为我一直以为创建独立国家的决定主要是受莫斯科的启发，而不是来自未来东德国家内部本身。那么，是否存在着这样一种未来或平行宇宙：20世纪50年代出现了一个统一的德国？还是说你认为二战结束的方式——
with the country split in two, the Red Army in one bit, the British, the Americans in another, do you think that meant the creation of East Germany was always inevitable? Well, as historians, we don't really like the idea of inevitability, I guess. But it's hard to see how a united Germany could have come out of this, because both sides, due to its sheer size and weight, there couldn't have been an Austrian kind of scenario where you end up with a neutral country that won't get involved in anything. That just doesn't work for where Germany is, for how big it is,
国家一分为二，红军在一边，英美在另一边——这意味着东德的建立是不可避免的？嗯，作为历史学家，我们其实不太喜欢“不可避免”这个概念，我想是的。但是很难看出一个统一的德国怎么能够从这种局面中诞生，因为由于德国纯粹的体量和分量，不可能出现像奥地利那样的情况——最终出现一个不参与任何事情的中立国。这对于德国所处的位置、它的大小、
for how much potential it has. I don't think it's ever possible to have a neutral Germany in the centre of Europe. And so it would have been, you know, even if you had it just for a short term, it would have been a playground for spies, undercover operations. People would have tried to influence the government elections, political parties from both sides. And I think it would have been unsustainable in the long run. I mean, you would have shifted, obviously, the Cold War, the Iron Curtain effectively further east. But at the same time, would the Russians have allowed Germany to become West Germany effectively?
它所具有的巨大潜力来说根本行不通。我认为在欧洲中心拥有一个中立的德国是绝对不可能的。所以，即使你让它只维持很短的一段时间，它也会成为间谍和秘密行动的游乐场。双方都会试图干预政府选举和政党。我认为从长远来看，这是不可持续的。我的意思是，你显然会把冷战、铁幕实际上向东推得更远。但与此同时，苏联人会允许德国变成西德那样吗？
And it would have possibly happened, this kind of idea of Konrad Adenauer in the West, the first West German chancellor, pulling West Germany so far to the West that it becomes part of NATO and remilitarizes very quickly. That would have scared, you know, Stalin to a point where he couldn't have accepted that. So I don't really see how it would have been possible to have one unified Germany without one side or the other trying to grasp it for themselves. And so Volta Olbricht, who I was delighted to read from you, had an unusually high pitch, so very high pitched voice. He said that of the state that he and his fellow communists were planning to set up, it has to look democratic, but we must have everything in our hands.
这很可能会发生，就像西德第一任总理阿登纳（Konrad Adenauer）在西场所做的那样，把西德拉向西方如此之远，以至于它成为了北约的一部分并迅速重新军事化。那会把斯大林吓得无法接受。所以我不认为在没有某一方试图将其据为己有的情况下，有可能出现一个统一的德国。所以，沃尔特·乌尔布里希特——我很高兴在你的书中读到，他的声音异常尖锐，音调非常高——他曾对由他和他的共产主义同僚们计划建立的国家这样说过：“它必须看起来是民主的，但我们必须把一切都掌握在自己手中。”
So that's a kind of cynical approach. It's like he's in the room, Tom. Well, thank you, Katja. Thank you. But at the same time, you also have a fair measure of brutality. So the Soviets are looting a lot of stuff. They're looting a lot of the industrial base. They're looting prehistoric gold treasures, all kinds of things. And people are going in and removing all the Junkers, the Prussian aristocrats. They're being kicked off their land. It's all being collectivized, all that kind of stuff.
这真是一种冷酷无情的方法。听起来他就好像在这个房间里一样。谢谢你，卡佳。谢谢。但与此同时，你也看到了相当程度的残酷。所以苏联人在大肆掠夺，掠夺了大量的工业基础，掠夺了史前黄金宝藏以及各种各样的东西。人们进去赶走所有的容克（Junkers，普鲁士地主贵族），把他们从土地上赶走。一切都被收归国有，实行集体化，诸如此类。
So it's a kind of familiar story from other East European countries and indeed actually from Germany under the Nazis. It's the combination of democratic approach combined with violence. Is that essentially how what becomes the GDR comes to be formed? Yeah, I think a lot of its origins go back to violence in various forms and repression as well. I mean, you have former Nazi concentration camps turned into what are now special Soviet camps, effectively, and anybody who's vaguely associated with the Nazis, and we're talking a lot of people here, you know, party members, people that were in the Hitler Youth and so on and so forth,
所以这是一个来自其他东欧国家、甚至是纳粹统治下的德国的熟悉故事。这是民主方法与暴力的结合。这基本上就是民主德国形成的方式吗？是的，我认为它的许多根源都可以追溯到各种形式的暴力和镇压。我的意思是，你看到前纳粹集中营被改造成了苏联的特殊集中营，任何与纳粹隐约沾边的人——我们这里指的是大量的人，你知道的，党员、加入过希特勒青年团的人等等——
end up in those camps. At the same time, as you say, there's lots of violence from the Soviet occupiers. That's looting on all sorts of levels. I mean, it starts on the personal level with the proverbial bicycle being ripped out of people's hands and goes all the way up to, you know know sort of organized uh looting from organized really by the state where they go into museums and clear them out that kind of thing um and then of course you got horrific violence towards the women and
最终都进了这些集中营。与此同时，正如你所说，来自苏联占领者的暴力比比皆是。各个层面的掠夺都在发生。我的意思是，它从个人层面开始，比如臭名昭著的自行车从人们手中被抢走，一直到由国家组织的大规模有组织掠夺——他们闯入博物馆洗劫一空，诸如此类。然后当然，对妇女和
children that were largely left by themselves because the men were off fighting still or in prison of war camps you know it's estimated that 2 million women were raped, for example. So all of these things are going on and they collectively, I think, lead to a sort of foundation trauma on a personal level, on a psychological level, as well as on an economic level. And that's something that the GDR has got to sort of try and recover from when the same level of violence does not apply to West Germany. Am I right in thinking that one thing that we would sometimes miss in this sort of Cold War
儿童施加了可怕的暴力，当时她们大部分都被独自留在家里，因为男人们还在前方打仗或关在战俘营里。据估计，有200万妇女遭到强奸。所以所有这些事情都在发生，我认为它们共同在个人层面、心理层面以及经济层面导致了一种创始创伤。而民主德国必须努力从中恢复过来，而西德却没有遭受同等程度的暴力。我是不是可以这样理解：我们在这种冷战史学中——如果你愿意这么称呼的话——有时可能会忽视的一点是，东德不仅仅诞生于创伤、暴力、镇压和偏执，其中也包含着大量的理想主义？所以如果你很年轻，假设你曾加入过希特勒青年团，你现在处于十几岁或快到二十岁的年纪。所以你知道了希特勒对你作出的所有承诺，
historiography, if you like, is that East Germany is not just born out of trauma and violence and repression and paranoia, but there's also a lot of idealism. So if you're young, let's say you're in the Hitler youth, you're now in your teens, late teens or something. So you've known all the promises that Hitler made to you. They've all turned out to be false. Society has fallen apart. And here are these guys who won the war, who beat you, and who are now saying, listen, a new world of freedom,
结果全都是假的。社会分崩离析。而现在，这些赢得了战争、打败了你的人却在说：“听着，一个充满自由、
of brotherhood, of internationalism, of equality. I mean, there are a lot of people who believe in that, aren't there? I mean, it's not just imposed on them. There are people who willingly and enthusiastically go along with it. Well, one of them is Angela Merkel's father, who's a pastor, who goes from West Germany to live in East Germany. And Bertolt Brecht, the great playwright, does. Absolutely.
兄弟情谊、国际主义和平等的新世界正在诞生。”我的意思是，有很多人对此深信不疑，对吧？我的意思是，这不仅仅是强加给他们的。有许多人是自愿且充满热情地顺应这一切的。嗯，其中一人就是安格拉·默克尔的父亲，他是一名牧师，从西德搬到东德生活。伟大的剧作家贝托尔特·布莱希特（Bertolt Brecht）也是如此。绝对是的。
And you get lots of people who believe that genuinely this is the new kind of Germany that hasn't been able to really found its foundation in the Weimar Republic. So again, you know, we go back to broken promises. That was another period where there was supposed to be real social change and social mobility and welfare and all of these kinds of inequality happening. And it didn't and it fell apart. And now there's this new Germany that is being set up and it did help that initially Stalin quite famously said the Hitler's come and go but the but the German state remains you know and this kind of idea that the the Soviets were almost despite all of the horrific stuff that happened and the great sacrifice that they made in the war
你会发现很多人真诚地相信，这就是那个在魏玛共和国时期未能真正稳固根基的新德国。所以，我们再次回到了那些被打破的承诺。那也是一个本应发生真正的社会变革、社会流动、福利以及各种平等现象的时期，但它没有发生，而是破灭了。现在，这个新德国正在建立。当时确实起到了一定帮助的是，斯大林早期曾说过一句名言：“希特勒来了又去，但德意志国家永存。”这种想法——即尽管发生了所有可怕的事情，以及他们在战争中付出了巨大牺牲，
that they were sort of almost willing to see the German people as a separate thing from Nazism when the western allies weren't quite willing to do that just yet, also gave people hope that things would maybe change. I mean, I've got one example that springs to mind is a woman called Regina Faustmann, who I've got in my book just as an ordinary East German, basically, who was a teenager at the time in her late teens and just really wanted to get going. She joined the Free German Youth straight away once it was set up, wanted to roll up her sleeve, collect scrap metal, start clearing the rubble away and sort of set up this new Germany
苏联人几乎还是愿意将德国人民与纳粹主义区分开来，而当时的西方盟友却还没有完全做到这一点——也给人们带来了事情可能会改变的希望。我的意思是，我脑海中浮现的一个例子是一个叫雷吉娜·福斯特曼（Regina Faustmann）的女性，我在书中提到了她，她当时只是一个普通的东德十几岁女孩，非常渴望大干一场。一旦自由德国青年联盟（Free German Youth）成立，她立刻就加入了进去，想要卷起袖子收集废金属，开始清理废墟，并着手建立这个许多人都真诚信仰的新德国。
that many people genuinely believed in. And presumably also, I mean, going from the 40s into the 50s, just the fact that there's a relative degree of normality must have generated both relief, but a certain sense of loyalty towards this kind of emergent communist state. Yeah, although I think that was also one of its faults that it couldn't provide that as quickly as the West could, where sort of economic stability due to the martial aid money effectively was able to be established a lot earlier than in East Germany. But at the same time, yes,
而且可以推测，从40年代过渡到50年代，仅仅是由于存在着相对程度的正常生活，一定既带来了松了一口气的感觉，也对这个新兴的共产主义国家产生了一种忠诚感。是的，尽管我认为这也是它的缺点之一，即它无法像西方那样迅速地提供这种正常生活。在西方，由于马歇尔计划资金的注入，经济稳定得以比东德早得多地建立起来。但与此同时，是的，
people did feel that they were creating something and they also felt they were creating it themselves. You know, there was a kind of defiance against the idea that they were almost like three steps back. And now they had to fight for themselves and create their own country with their own heart graft, as it were. And that really had appealed to a lot of people as well. And at that point, so we're talking late 40s, early 50s, you can move quite freely from one Germany to the other, am I right? So in other words, if you want to get a new job, or if you just say, golly, this, I hate this communism, not working, you literally just park your stuff in the car, if you have a car or you hitch or whatever, and you move 100 miles to the west. And it's as simple as that.
人们确实觉得他们在创造某些东西，他们也觉得是他们自己亲手创造了它。你知道，有一种反抗情绪，对抗那种“后退了三步”的想法，现在他们必须为自己奋斗，用自己的双手辛勤耕耘来创建自己的国家。这确实也吸引了很多人。而在那个时候——也就是40年代末、50年代初——你可以非常自由地从一个德国移动到另一个德国，我没记错吧？换句话说，如果你想找一份新工作，或者你只是说：“天哪，我讨厌这个共产主义，它根本行不通，”你字面意义上就可以把东西打包放到车里（如果你有车的话），或者搭便车什么的，然后搬到100英里外的西方去。事情就这么简单吗？
Am I, is that right? Yep, to start with, absolutely. I mean, they did pretty early on and mostly 1952 onwards, beef up that long inner German border between the two states rather than the one in Berlin. But the Berlin one stays open until the Berlin Wall is erected. So there is that choice and many, many people take it. That's one of the early challenges that this kind of young state and even the Soviet zone has got to cope with as well.
我、我没记错吧？是的，一开始完全是这样的。我的意思是，他们相当早（主要从1952年开始）就加强了两个国家之间漫长的德国内部边界，而不是柏林的那条边界。但柏林的边界一直保持开放，直到柏林墙建立。所以确实有这种选择，而且成千上万的人都作出了这样的选择。这也是这个年轻国家乃至苏联占领区不得不应对的早期挑战之一。
And so in the early 50s, you have a continual drain. So we're talking about hundreds of thousands of people from East to West. And these are people who are anxious, presumably, it must be a combination of things. So is it the economy must be part of it because the economy in the west is reviving more quickly but are people now beginning to think so tom was talking about the democratic means they have this very strange electoral system where they basically print out all the names of the winners and then you put it in the ballot box also known as paper folding by the east german population yeah about that point to people thinking actually this is a terrible sham i've now seen through the lies. I'm off. I'm going to
所以在50年代初，你看到了持续不断的人口流失——我们说的是成百上千万人从东部流向西部。这些人很焦虑，可以推测，这一定是由多种因素结合导致的。所以经济肯定是其中一部分，因为西部的经济恢复得更快；但人们现在是否开始在想——所以汤姆刚才谈到了民主手段，他们有一种非常奇怪的选举制度，基本上就是把所有获胜者的名字印出来，然后你把它塞进投票箱，这也被东德人民称为“折纸选举”——关于这一点，人们是否开始觉得：“实际上，这是一个可怕的骗局，我已经看穿了这些谎言。我走了，我要去法兰克福或别的什么地方。”而且，还有史塔西，对吧？那是1950年建立的。是的，
Frankfurt or whatever. And also, you've got the Stasi, haven't you? So that's initiated in 1950. Yeah. And it comes very large, very quickly. So is that sense of oppression also something that people are fleeing? Yes. Although most of the evidence seems to point in the direction that economic factors seems to be by a long way the biggest pull. The West German government, because they were overwhelmed with refugees both from East Germany and from the territories in Eastern Europe that Germany had lost after the Second World War, they set up refugee camps. And when people arrived there, they filled in surveys as to why they were there and what they wanted to do with their lives. And the results of those show that you know the vast majority of people are there because they seek economic betterment and that's not just to say
而且它的规模迅速扩大。所以这种压迫感也是人们逃离的原因吗？是的。尽管大部分证据似乎表明，经济因素似乎在很大程度上是最大的吸引力。西德政府因为既要应对来自东德的难民，又要应对二战后德国失去的东欧领土上的难民，而不堪重负，于是他们设立了难民营。当人们到达那里时，他们会填写调查问卷，说明他们为什么来到这里以及他们想在生活中做些什么。调查结果显示，绝大多数人来这里是因为他们追求更好的经济条件，这不仅是指“我多赚了一点钱”，而是实际上货架上有商品。你知道，粮食供应情况仍然极不稳定，东德不得不维持配给制比西德长得多，你知道，这是非常基础的经济问题。如果人们想为自己和家人寻求稳定的生活条件，西部是一个非常具有吸引力的选择，特别是如果你拥有在重建德国过程中迫切需要的技能。所以这些是像熟练工人，
i'm earning a little bit more but actually having goods on the shelves you know the situation with food was still incredibly unstable east germany had to keep rationing up much much longer than than west germany did and you know this is pretty fundamental economic stuff and if people are unstable. East Germany had to keep rationing up much, much longer than West Germany did. And, you know, this is pretty fundamental economic stuff. And if people are wanting kind of secure conditions for themselves and their family, the West is a very attractive option, particularly if you have got a skill that's desperately needed in the rebuilding of Germany. So these are like, skilled workers, for example, medical personnel example medical personnel doctors nurses those kinds of people who are really taken in with warm welcomes in the west and will find much much more stable
例如医务人员，医生、护士这样的人，他们在西部受到了热烈的欢迎，并在那里找到了稳定得多的生活条件。关于难民，我想插一句，我和汤姆都举手了，求求了，老师，求求了，这话题太有趣了。关于难民，我读到时惊呆了：东德四分之一的人口竟然是由难民组成的，他们大概是从前东普鲁士、苏台德地区逃出来的。这一定极其不稳定。我的意思是，你不得不安置所有这些从别处赶来的人，而所有的住房都被红军夷为平地了。是的，绝对如此。所以一开始就没有足够的住房存量。这纯粹是人数的问题。
conditions there just one quick thing about refugees someone i both have our hands up please miss please miss it says how interesting this topic is so just on refugees i was absolutely gobsmacked to read that a quarter of East Germany's population is made up of refugees who have fled presumably from the former East Prussia, from the Sudetenland. So that must be incredibly destabilizing. I mean, you're having to house all these people who have arrived from somewhere else. And all the housing has been flattened by the Red Army. Yeah, absolutely. So there isn't enough housing stock to start with. It's just a sheer number.
你有1200到1400万人逃离了这些领土，而他们中的绝大多数仅出于地理原因，基本上都涌入了东德。以我自己的家族背景为例，我的四个祖父母中有三个也来自那里——东普鲁士、苏台德和波美拉尼亚。他们字面意义上步行了几个月，我祖父甚至步行了几年，直到1947年才抵达。所以人们到达那里确实花了很长时间，然后他们到达了一个别人并不欢迎他们的地方，因为当地人自己也在艰难维持生计，
You've got 12 to 14 million people fleeing those territories, and the vast majority of them arrived for geographical reasons alone, basically, in East Germany. My own family background, I've got three of my four grandparents come from there as well, East Prussia, Sudetenland, and Pomerania, where they literally kind of walked for months, one of them years my grandfather only arrived and i think it's 47 um so it did take a long time basically for for people to get there and then they arrived somewhere where people didn't want them because they were struggling with their own uh conditions
而且没有足够的住房。于是地方当局会说：“好吧，你可以搬去跟这个农民住，因为他有个空闲的谷仓。”而农民根本没有发言权。所以，人们最终不得不为收留他们的那些人免费工作很长时间。如果你刚从东部逃来，当地的学龄儿童对你也不会特别友好。所以一开始这并不是什么好状况。我认为，这种局面在导致社会动荡的程度上常常被低估了。所以各种压力、各种紧张局势交织在一起。1953年，爆发了一场起义。那么，这背后的故事是怎样的？究竟是什么具体事件促成了它？东德国民政府又是如何应对这场起义的？
and there wasn't enough housing and then local authorities would say well you can move in with this farmer because he's got a barn somewhere that he isn't using. And the farmer didn't really get a say in this. So, you know, people ended up basically working for free for a long time for the people that they were put up with. The local school children wouldn't be particularly nice to you if you've just arrived from the east. So it wasn't a great situation to start with. And I think one that's often underestimated in terms of how destabilising that is for society. So all kinds of pressures, all kinds of tensions. And in 1953, there is an uprising. So what's the
嗯，他们试图同时做太多事情。除了我们刚提到的所有问题之外，他们在能源方面也面临巨大危机——在实际生产暖气方面，褐煤真的是他们唯一的资源，这极其低效，而且对环境相当有害。但所有这些问题同时爆发了。与此同时，民主德国的缔造者沃尔特·乌尔布里希特却在强行推行他的“社会主义建设”计划，这包括对土地的使用方式进行大规模重组或某种形式的改革。
story of that? What specifically precipitates it? And how does the East German state deal with that? Well, they try to do too many things at once. All of the problems that we just mentioned, on top of that, you've got a huge with energy um in terms of actually producing heat you know brown coal really is the only thing that they've got which is ridiculously inefficient and obviously quite bad for the environment as well but all of these things come at once and at the same time walter olbrich the sort of founding father of the gdr if you, presses ahead with this build-up of socialism program, which entails, for example, a large restructuring or kind of reformation of the way that land is used.
所以，正如你刚才所说，他从容克手中夺走土地，也从其他大型农场主手中夺走土地，将其切割成小块，然后分给所有被称为“新农民”的人。实际上，例如那些从东部来的人，现在分到了相当于好几个足球场大小的土地，但这根本不够大，无法进行高效的生产。因此，农业部门崩溃了。所以所有这些事情都在发生。
So he takes away land from the Junkers, as you said earlier, but also from other sort of large farmers, cuts it up into small chunks, and then gives it to all of these people who are called new farmers. Effectively, people, for instance, those that come from the East, are now given several football fields worth of land, and it just isn't big enough to be used productively. And therefore, the agricultural sector breaks down. So there's all of this kind of stuff happening.
意识形态与现实生活中的经济残酷现实相冲突，最终导致了一种什么东西都极度匮乏的局面。不仅如此，他们还在试图建立早期的武装力量、安全部队、警察、史塔西。从1952年起，他们还在加固边境。这实在太多了。而且他们把所有这些压力都压在了工人们身上。结果就是付出越来越多的劳动，却换来更少的回报。
Ideology clashes with the economic realities on the ground, and you end up with a situation where there's just not enough of anything. And on top of that, they're trying to build up the early sort of armed forces, security forces, police, Stasi. They're trying to beef up the border from 1952 onwards. It's just too much. And they're asking all of that of the workers. And it becomes more and more and more work for less outcome.
甚至连你赚取的那点微薄薪水，实际上也买不到任何东西，因为货架上空空如也。因此，人们变得极其不满。他们向西眺望，看着就在国境线另一边发生的经济奇迹。许多人在那里有亲戚，亲戚们告诉他们一切是多么美好，他们是如何找回所有的稳定与繁荣的。而他们对现状感到极不满意。他们看到这一切部分是由政权的行为造成的。因此，一种日益增长的愤怒感油然而生，特别是在工人阶级当中，考虑到这是一个工农国家，这显得有些讽刺。这是一个工人的天堂。确实如此。所以，在1953年的夏天，爆发了大规模抗议。
And even the little money that you do get, you can't actually buy anything with it because there's nothing on the shelves. And so people are becoming incredibly unhappy. They're looking west towards the economic miracle that's happening just across the border. Many people have got relatives there who tell them how good everything is and how they've got all of the stability and the prosperity back. And they're just unhappy with this. And they see that this is partially caused by the actions of the regime. And hence, you get kind of a growing sense of anger, particularly amongst the working classes, which is somewhat ironic, given that you have a workers and peasants state. It's a workers' paradise. Indeed. And so there's the summer of 1953, there's mass protests.
所以在6月16日左右，这一切达到了高潮。我想问题是，在那个时候，为什么东德政权没有倒台？是因为有足够多的人利益与体制绑定吗？是因为他们有红军在背后撑腰吗？为什么我们在1953年没有直接迎来1989年呢？是的，我的意思是，主要的论点是红军进行了干预。他们宣布进入紧急状态，字面意义上开着坦克和久经沙阵的指挥官碾压进来，残酷地镇压了这场起义。我要说的是另一个原因：许多人只是随大流加入进去了。很多当时在场的人——我听取了他们的证词或查看了证据——他们最深刻的感受是：“我往窗外一看，外面有人在做事，而且我也有点不高兴，所以我出去了，加入了他们。”而一当坦克开过来，这些人立刻就回到了屋里，说：“其实，我没那么不高兴，一切都会好的。”你知道的，因为苏联人紧接着对乌尔布里希特说：“你们需要把这事处理好。我们之前就告诉过你，你不能像现在这样以极快的速度建设社会主义，因为这行不通，它会破坏一切稳定。”所以从本质上讲，乌尔布里希特比斯大林还要共产主义，他比斯大林更斯大林化，他试图向斯大林证明他比斯大林更斯大林化。绝对是这样的。
So right about the 16th of June, it all sort of reaches a climax. And I suppose the question is, at that point, why doesn't the East German regime fall? Is it because there are enough people with a stake in the system? Is it because they're backed up by the Red Army? Why don't we have 1989 then in 1953? Yeah, I mean, the main argument is that the Red Army intervened. They declared a state of emergency and literally roll in there with tanks and kind of battle-hardened commanders and suppresses uprising brutally. I would say another reason is that many people just joined in. So many of the people that were there were, I kind of listened
嗯，是的，对斯大林来说——关键点在于保持东德的存在——我的意思是，斯大林此时虽然已经去世了，但其遗留的影响依然存在。如果你遇到这样一种情况：东德必须存在，以便为苏联人提供资源、支付赔偿并受到经济剥削，而如果你的工人们不来上班，整个国家陷入混乱，你不得不派遣自己的军队和资源前去协助，那么这种情况就无法维持。而这正是让苏联人如此不情愿支持乌尔布里希特所追求的那种极其迅速和具有破坏性的社会主义建设的原因。事后，在事情发生之后，苏联人对他们说：“好吧，你们可以留在这里。”原因之一是斯大林刚刚去世，而作为继任者崭露头角的赫鲁晓夫，并不希望在自己试图应对俄罗斯国内动荡的同时，东德也发生剧烈动荡。
to their testimony or looked at the evidence. The overwhelming sense was, I looked out of my window and there were people out there doing things and I was a bit unhappy as well. So I went out and joined them. And those people immediately literally went back inside the moment the tanks rolled up and said, actually, I'm not that unhappy. It'll be fine. You know, and because straight after the Soviets basically said to Ulbricht, you need to sort this out. We told you beforehand, you can't build up socialism as quickly as you have done because it doesn't work and it destabilizes everything so essentially ulbricht is more communist than star he's more stalinist than stalin he's trying to prove to stalin that he's more stalinist than stalin absolutely um yeah and stalin was you know kind of the main point was to keep east germany i mean stalin's obviously dead at this point but the legacy of that remains but if you have the
他们对乌尔布里希特说：“你现在需要确保人民拥有体面的生活水平。首先关注这一点。其他一切都可以随后再说。”因此，乌尔布里希特被迫从他的社会主义建设中退一步，允许一点经济自由。苏联人也字面意义上用卡车运送食品和其他物资，试图帮助改善局势。局势稍微稳定了一些，镇压也减轻了。因为你提出的其中一个观点是，事实上，乌尔布里希特在经历了纳粹等等事情之后，对自己的同胞有着相当深的不信任感。我的意思是，他并不真的相信他们会做正确的事情。所以这就是原因之一。
situation where east germ Germany needs to be there for the Soviets to provide resources, to pay reparations and to be exploited economically. And that doesn't work if your workers don't turn up and if the whole state erupts into chaos, and you have to send your own forces and your own resources in to help out. And this was what made the Soviets so reluctant to support this kind of really rapid and destructive buildup of socialism that Ulbricht is pursuing. And afterwards, after it had happened, the Soviets said to them, well, you can stay here. And one of the reasons is that Stalin had just died and Khrushchev, who's just emerging as the sort of successor, doesn't want upheaval in East Germany whilst he's trying to deal with the zone upheaval in Russia.
这种情况是，东德需要存在以向苏联提供资源、支付赔偿金并在经济上受到剥削。如果工人不出勤，整个国家陷入混乱，你不得不派遣自己的军队和资源前去协助，那么这是行不通的。正是这一点让苏联人极不愿意支持乌布利希正在追求的那种真正迅速且具有破坏性的社会主义建设。在此之后，事情发生后，苏联人对他们说，好吧，你们可以留在这里。原因之一是斯大林刚刚去世，作为接班人崭露头角的赫鲁晓夫在试图处理俄罗斯自身的动荡时，不希望东德也发生动荡。
They're saying to him, you need to now make sure that people have got decent living standards. Focus on that first. Everything else can come after. And Warburg is thereby forced to sort of take a step back from his buildup of socialism, allow a little bit of economic freedom. And the Soviets are also sending truckloads literally of kind of foodstuffs and other things to try and help with the situation. It stabilizes a bit. And repression is scaled down as well. Because one of the points you make is that actually Ulbricht, after all his experiences with the Nazis and so on, has actually quite a deep mistrust of his compatriots. I mean, he doesn't really trust them to do the right thing. And so that's one of the reasons why
他们对他说，你现在需要确保人们拥有像样的生活水平。首先关注这一点。其他一切都可以随后再说。因此，瓦尔堡被迫从他的社会主义建设中退后一步，允许一点经济自由。苏联人也字面意义上派遣了一车又一车食品和其他物资来试图帮助解决这种情况。局势稳定了一点。镇压也有所减少。因为你提出的观点之一实际上是，乌布利希在经历了纳粹等等事情之后，对他的同胞其实有着相当深的 không信任（不信任）。我的意思是，他并不真正信任他们会做正确的事。所以这也是原因之一
there's such a measure of coercion in his kind of approach. Yeah. And he doesn't understand them either. And I suppose in the long run, why the Iron Curtain and most notoriously the Berlin Wall in the end go up, because he can't rely on his fellow citizens in East Germany not to head west. Yeah, I mean, one of the fundamental issues with him, and I would say with Honecker later as well, is that they weren't there during the war. They didn't understand what had happened in Germany for this entire period. And when you think how extreme Nazism is as an ideology, what it did to the country and the people that were there weren't the same anymore. It's interesting as well when you look at, for instance, Wolfgang Leonhard, who is one of the young communists who was sent back from Russia to Germany to build up socialism. He'd left Berlin as a teenager and then returned in 1945
这种方法的胁迫色彩太浓了。是的。而且他也无法理解他们。我想，从长远来看，为什么铁幕、尤其是臭名昭著的柏林墙最终会建立起来，就是因为他无法相信东德的同胞不会逃往西方。是的，我的意思是，他面临的根本问题之一，以及后来昂纳克面临的问题，就是他们在战争期间不在场。他们不明白在这整段时期里德国发生了什么。当你想到纳粹主义作为一种意识形态是多么极端，它对这个国家造成了什么影响时，留在那里的人民已经不再是原来的样子了。当你看到沃尔夫冈·莱昂哈德（Wolfgang Leonhard）的例子时，这也很有趣，他是一位年轻的共产主义者，被从俄国派回德国建设社会主义。他十几岁时离开柏林，然后在1945年返回
to find that it's completely changed, not just physically, but that he doesn't get what people want, how they feel about things, the fact that they feel that the Russians, as they called them, or the Moscovites coming back, they weren't proper Germans anymore. They'd betrayed the country in some shape or form, or that was the feeling that people had. know they were totally disconnected and the workers still want to talk in 1953 to Ulbricht they walk up to his ministry and stand in front of it and say come out and speak to us and he just goes I think it's going to start raining soon they'd soon go
发现一切都彻底变了，不仅是物理形态上的变化，而且他根本无法理解人们想要什么，他们对事物的感受，以及他们觉得俄罗斯人（或者他们所说的莫斯科归来者）已经不再是真正的德国人了。他们以某种形式背叛了国家，或者说那是人们当时心中的感受。你知道他们完全脱节了，而工人们在1953年仍然想和乌布里希特对话，他们走到他的部委门前站在那儿说，出来跟我们谈谈，而他却说，我猜马上就要下雨了，他们很快就会走开的
it'd be fine you know it just shows how disconnected these people were from the people that they were trying to to lead and I think that was one of the fundamental problems they never get rid of. So it's a period of relative stability, the 50s, but there's a continuing drain. Then to deal with that drain of people, in 1961, they put up the Berlin Wall. We did a podcast, didn't we, Tom, with Ian McGregor about the Berlin Wall? So one of the things you talk about the Berlin Wall that's quite sort of counterintuitive is the Berlin Wall actually I mean it freezes the situation but it ensures stability so there's almost an argument this will sound like an absolutely weird thing to say but there's actually an argument to be made for the Berlin Wall in the sense that it means that the sort of
一切都会好起来的，你知道的，这恰恰表明这些人与他们试图领导的人民是多么脱节，我认为这是他们永远无法摆脱的根本问题之一。所以20世纪50年代是一个相对稳定的时期，但人员流失一直在继续。为了应对这种人口外流，他们在1961年修筑了柏林墙。汤姆，我们不是和伊恩·麦格雷戈（Ian McGregor）一起做过关于柏林墙的播客吗？所以关于柏林墙，你谈到的一点相当有违直觉，那就是柏林墙实际上——我的意思是它冻结了局势，但它确保了稳定，所以几乎有一种争论——这听起来可能是一件非常奇怪的事情，但实际上关于柏林墙确实有一种观点，那就是它意味着某种
the threat of instability recedes and actually from the East German point of view people just have to now knuckle down and make german point of view people just have to now knuckle down and make the best of the regime they have because there is no alternative is that is that pretty much your view yeah i mean that's that's certainly how it was viewed by most of the political leaders at the time you've got ardenauer doing very very little in west germany about the saying very little about it as well the same goes for kennedy you know and obviously all baked himself as happy in east germ Germany because it stabilizes the situation. But it's interesting how little kind of political resistance there is and also how little resistance there is on the ground.
不稳定的威胁退去了，实际上从东德的角度来看，人们现在只能咬紧牙关，适应现有的政权，并充分利用它，因为别无选择，这——这基本上就是你的看法吗？是的，我的意思是，这当然是当时大多数政治领导人的看法。阿登纳在西德几乎没做什么，对此也鲜有表态。肯尼迪也是如此，显然乌布里希特本人在东德也很高兴，因为它稳定了局势。但有趣的是，政治抵抗是如此之少，民间的抵抗也是如此之少。
I mean, yes, you do get a lot of unrest in Berlin itself, particularly actually more on the western side than in East Berlin. You do get that. But the rest of the country is surprisingly quiet. And I asked almost all of the people I spoke to, you know, this was one of my key questions, irrespective of what I actually wanted from them interview wise, like, what did you make of the building of the Berlin Wall? And the vast majority of them kind of shrugged their shoulders and said, well, I was on holiday. I read about it in the newspaper newspaper i suppose it was quite good because our doctor now had to stay yeah um but they had no particular feelings about it because they were working class people who'd never traveled anywhere beforehand they lived in their communities where they always lived um and there was no possibility whatever happened you know of them
我的意思是，是的，柏林本身的骚乱确实很多，尤其是西柏林一侧比东柏林还要多。确实如此。但全国其他地方却出奇地安静。我几乎问过我交谈过的所有人，你知道的，这是我的核心问题之一，无论我从采访中实际想要得到什么，比如：你怎么看柏林墙的修建？绝大多数人都耸耸肩膀说，哦，我在度假呢。我在报纸上读到过，我想这挺好的，因为我们的阿登纳不得不留下来了，但是他们对这件事没有什么特别的感受，因为他们是以前从未去过任何地方的工人阶级，他们一直住在自己熟悉的社区里，而且无论发生什么，他们都不可能
to move away and go somewhere else so in many ways it economically stabilized the situation and it also now meant that albrecht was put in a situation where he had to make life worthwhile in the GDR now that he'd locked people into it. And that in itself created a lot of social and economic change in the 60s because he had to ease the sort of tensions a little bit economically and try and build a stable country. So the Berlin Wall has gone up. And when we come back, we'll look at the decades between that and the Berlin Wall coming down again in 1989. We'll look at Trabants, fridges, steroids, all the kind of stuff that we associate with East Germany. So we'll be back after the break.
搬走去别的地方。所以在很多方面，它在经济上稳定了局势，而且现在也意味着乌布里希特被置于这样一种境地：既然他已经把人们锁在里面，他就必须让民主德国的生活变得值得过。这本身在60年代创造了大量的社会和经济变革，因为他必须在经济上稍微缓和一下紧张局势，并试图建立一个稳定的国家。因此，柏林墙已经建立。当我们回来时，我们将回顾从那到1989年柏林墙倒塌之间的几十年。我们将看看卫星轿车、冰箱、类固醇，以及所有我们与东德联系在一起的东西。所以我们休息一下，一会儿回来。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip
我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐至上》这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和八卦花絮的固定栏目
and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad free listening bonus episodes
在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部，如果你想收听无广告的节目、收听独家番外剧集
and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com that's therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. East Berlin, 7th October 1989. I was four years old, an excited little girl with unruly pitch black hair that resisted every attempt to control it. Wrapping my hands around the handrail of the rotating visitor platform of the Berlin television tower, I was straining forward to get as close to the panoramic glass pan look like little ants. I pointed downwards eagerly, jumping up and down, so I could see better. And look, there are police cars everywhere.
并优先获得现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com，网址是 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。东柏林，1989年10月7日。我当时四岁，是一个兴奋的小女孩，留着一头怎么也梳理不服帖的乌黑蓬乱的头发。我双手紧紧抓住柏林电视塔旋转观景平台的扶手，身体向前倾，尽量靠近全景玻璃窗，俯瞰着下方像小蚂蚁一样的人群。我兴奋地指着下方，上蹿下跳，希望能看得更清楚。看啊，到处都是警车。
These last words made my father stop in his tracks. Looking down at the increasingly crowded square at the foot of the Fernstittum, his face went white. He recognised the armoured vehicles as belonging to paramilitary people's police units. Many of the people I was pointing at were protesters. So that was from Katya's new book, Beyond the Wall and Katya, that is your experience
这最后几个话让我父亲停下了脚步。看着电视塔脚下越来越拥挤的广场，他的脸色变白了。他认出那些装甲车属于准军事治安警察部队。我指着的许多人都是抗议者。这段内容选自卡佳的新书《越过高墙》，卡佳，这就是你的经历
in 1989 watching... Tom, so gallant of you to read that yourself rather than to let Katya read her. It was very weird watching Katya listen to you ventriloquizing her four-year-old. That's what we were all about. It's a hall of mirrors, a hall of mirrors. So an amazing passage.
在1989年目睹……汤姆，你亲自朗读而不是让卡佳自己读，真是太绅士了。看着卡佳听你用腹语模仿她四岁时的声音，感觉真的很诡异。这就是我们的全部意义所在。这是一个镜厅，一个镜厅。真是一段精彩的文字。
And it kind of introduces you as a character into the story that you're describing. It reminds, you know, it's kind of lived vivid personal history. And we left the first episode, the Berlin Wall had been set up. That's 1989, the down episode, the Berlin Wall had been set up. That's 1989, the downfall of the Berlin Wall. Let's look at the decades between those two great events. So first of all, the politics of it. Ulbricht is kind of hanging around like a slightly rotten smell. But coming up on the outside track, we have Erich Honecker, who you mentioned before. And he also has a very high-pitched voice. And additionally,
它把你作为一个角色引入了你所描述的故事中。这提醒人们，你知道的，这是一种真实生动的个人历史。我们结束第一集时，柏林墙已经建成了。那是1989年，也就是柏林墙倒塌的那一集。让我们来看看这两大事件之间的几十年。首先，是政治层面。乌布里希特就像一股微酸的气味一样四处晃荡。但在暗中追赶的，是我们之前提到过的埃里希·昂纳克。他也有一副很高的嗓音，此外，
he likes to mumble. So what is it about East German politicians and high-pitched voices? I think people forget to some extent that they're not career politicians. They're working-class people that come from fairly down-to-ear earth, if you want to call it that, sort of backgrounds with no pretense of being particularly polished or particularly apt at kind of portraying a certain image in public. And they found it incredibly awkward at times to do just that.
他喜欢嘟囔。那么，东德政客和高音调之间到底有什么联系呢？我想人们在某种程度上忘记了他们不是职业政客。他们是工薪阶层，背景相当接地气——如果你愿意这么称呼的话——他们并不标榜自己有多么老练，或者在公众面前塑造某种形象方面有多么精明。他们有时会发现要做到这一点简直尴尬极了。
And especially Honegger, you see him a lot with like foreign politicians and he stands there almost shyly, sort of wringing his hands or mumbling, you know, literally sort of, well, not literally, he hasn't got a beard, but mumbling into his beard. It's easy to forget that these aren't people that come from a, like,
特别是昂纳克，你经常看到他和外国政客在一起，他站在那里几乎有些害羞，双手绞在一起或者嘟囔着，你知道的，字面意义上的——好吧，也不是字面意义上的，他没有胡子——但对着他的胡子嘟囔。人们很容易忘记，这些人并不出身于一个，呃，
well-bred and well-educated background, but, you know, they are a roofer and a carpenter, and they come from backgrounds where you don't, you know, speak particularly eloquently or present yourself particularly confidently. And Honecker, fascinatingly, is not from the territory of East Germany. So he is from the West, right? Where's he from? Yeah, he's from the Saarland.
出身良好、受过良好教育的背景，而是，你知道的，他们是屋顶工人和木匠，他们的背景决定了你不会——你知道的——说话特别有文采，或者表现得特别自信。而有趣的是，昂纳克并不是东德本土人。所以他是西方人，对吧？他是哪里人？对，他是萨尔兰人。
And they naturally have kind of like a very soft accent. It's hard to describe in English, but it lends itself to being rather difficult to understand. Oh, yeah, all that kind of stuff. And he grows up with a pig, I gather, again, from your book, which is a wonderful detail. And he comes in 1971, Ulbricht basically gets deposed, doesn't he? It's kind of the Soviets lean on him and he gets pushed out.
他们自然有一种非常柔和的口音。在英语里很难形容，但它导致人们相当难以理解。哦，是的，所有诸如此类的事情。我从你的书中了解到，他甚至是和一头猪一起长大的，这是一个绝妙的细节。他在1971年上台，乌布里希特基本上被废黜了，不是吗？这有点像苏联人向他施压，然后他被挤走了。
And so Honecker comes in. So Honecker made his name, well, not made his name, but Honecker in the 60s had been a great critic of the Beatles and of long hair and of youth culture. So Honecker is the sort of, he's precisely the wrong person you could argue to take over, isn't he, in the early 70s because he's so backward-looking and puritanical. But I thought that he was piling in and allowing all these
于是昂纳克上台了。所以昂纳克成名了——嗯，也不能说成名，但昂纳克在60年代一直是披头士乐队、长发以及青年文化的强烈批评者。所以昂纳克这种人，可以说是在70年代初接掌权力的绝对错误人选，不是吗？因为他是如此思想落后且清教徒。但我原以为他会大举介入并允许所有这些
German youth to buy jeans and things. Yeah, those things are both true. So, I mean, this is one of the things I find fascinating about the GDR is just how much it oscillates between trying to open itself up and becoming more reformist and then drawing back in on itself. And I think that's reflected in both Ulbricht and Honecker. So Honecker actually opposes some of the opening up that Ulbricht does in the 60s, when he genuinely sits down with some youth leaders and says,
德国青年购买牛仔裤之类的东西。是的，这两点都是真的。所以，我的意思是，这是我对民主德国感到着迷的事情之一，就是它在试图开放和变得更加改良主义，与重新收缩自身之间摇摆得有多么厉害。我认为这在乌布里希特和昂纳克身上都得到了反映。因此，昂纳克实际上反对乌布里希特在60年代所做的一些开放举措，当时乌布里希特曾真诚地与一些青年领导人坐在一起说：
well, why is it that you're bored with our regime? Why are people leaving the free German youth? And then it's trying to open up by allowing a bit more Western music in, for example, and other things. And Honecker at that point is opposed to it. And then it almost turns around on its head when Ulbricht is ousted for being too old, too stubborn, too lectury, basically constantly trying to tell East Germans how to live their lives. And Honecker comes in and presents himself as the fresh breath of air who will bring in reforms and create a new country. Because it's not just jeans, is it? It's also Dean Reed, the Red Elvis, who's an American enthusiast for communism, who comes over and it becomes their kind of Elvis, great rock and roll star. Yeah, he suited Honecker perfectly. I mean, you've got this kind of brash, handsome American
好吧，为什么你们会对我们的政权感到厌烦？为什么人们要离开自由德国青年联盟？然后通过允许引入更多西方音乐等方式来试图开放。而昂纳克当时是反对这一点的。然后，当乌布里希特因为太老、太固执、太喜欢说教——基本上就是不断地告诉东德人如何过生活——而被赶下台时，局势几乎来了个180度大转弯。昂纳克上台后，把自己包装成一股带来改革和创造一个新国家的新鲜空气。因为这不仅仅是牛仔裤的事，对吧？还有迪恩·里德（Dean Reed），也就是“红色猫王”，他是一个热衷于共产主义的美国人，他来到这里，成为了他们自己的那种猫王、伟大的摇滚巨星。是的，他非常适合昂纳克。我的意思是，你有这样一个狂妄、英俊的美国人
with the great flashy smile who comes along and sings like Western music and country songs and things that look and sound like the West does to sort of East Germans. But at the same time, he's a convinced communist and has been sort of touring the Soviet Union and become a huge star there. And it's kind of ideologically reliable, if you will. So he settles down in East Germany, marries an East German woman and becomes kind of Honecker's pet cowboy, if you will, to some extent, by projecting a Western image, but doing it in a communist way.
带着灿烂耀眼的微笑来到这里，唱着西方音乐、乡村歌曲以及对东德人来说看起来和听起来就像西方那样的东西。但与此同时，他是一个坚定的共产主义者，曾在苏联巡演并在那里成为巨星。从意识形态上讲，如果你愿意的话，他是可靠的。因此他在东德定居，娶了一名东德女子，并在某种程度上成为了昂纳克的宠物牛仔——如果你愿意这么说的话——通过投射出一种西方形象，但却以一种共产主义的方式来做到这一点。
Since Tom's brought some music, are they called the Pudies? How would you call them? Yeah, Pudies. P-U-H-D music, are they called the Pudies? How would you call them? Yeah, Pudies. P-U-H-D-Y-S. The Pudies. And they're the biggest East German band. Massive. If I went to Leipzig now
既然汤姆带来了音乐，他们叫“普蒂斯”（Pudies）吗？你会怎么称呼他们？是的，“普蒂斯”。P-U-H-D 音乐，他们叫“普蒂斯”吗？你会怎么称呼他们？是的，“普蒂斯”。P-U-H-D-Y-S。“普蒂斯”。他们是东德最大的乐队。规模庞大。如果我现在去莱比锡
and started chatting to people about the Pudies, they'd know who I was talking about. Yeah, they're still around. They still give concerts to thousands of people now. I mean, the kind of lineup has changed a little bit over the years, but they're still going. So the point of those bands is they're not covering Western songs.
开始和人们聊起“普蒂斯”，他们会知道我在说谁。是的，他们还在。他们现在仍然在为成千上万的人举办音乐会。我的意思是，阵容这些年来有所变化，但他们还在继续。所以这些乐队的重点是他们不翻唱西方歌曲。
They're doing their own songs in German, and they're not tainted by imperialist capitalists. Forward to the Future with Conrad Honecker. Yeah, it's like absolute smash hit. No, they are an interesting one, actually, because they started off playing Western music as cover songs, as many GDR bands did, in sort of just pubs and and village halls and stuff like that and then the local Stasi got a bit annoyed with that because
他们用德语演唱自己的歌曲，并且没有受到帝国主义资本者的玷污。与昂纳克一起走向未来。是的，这真是一首超级热门歌曲。不，实际上他们是一个有趣的例子，因为他们一开始和许多民主德国乐队一样，只在酒吧、乡村礼堂之类的地方把西方音乐当作翻唱歌曲来演奏，然后当地的斯塔西对此有点恼火，因为
they were so um effective for lack of a better word and creating a a kind of exuberant atmosphere that that they got you know young people up dancing and it was incredibly rowdy and and they were unhappy with that so they told them they can't play anymore and banned them from from public appearances and the poodies actually to their credit went back and said like well what is it that we need to do to try and you know to try and please you so much that we can play again um and the authorities said to them if you write your own songs rather than covering western songs and you you play them in, absolutely fine, go back. And so they kind of stayed with their heroes in the West, like Uriah Heep, for example, that entire era, style-wise, but wrote their own German lyrics to go with it. And that worked so well that they
他们——由于缺乏更好的词汇——在营造一种生机勃勃的氛围方面非常有效，他们让年轻人跳起舞来，而且极其喧闹，他们对此很不满意，所以他们告诉他们不能再演出了，并禁止他们在公共场合露面。而“普蒂斯”为了他们的声誉，居然回过头去说：“嗯，我们需要做些什么，才能尽量取悦你们，好让我们能再次演出呢？”而当局对他们说：“如果你写自己的歌曲而不是翻唱西方歌曲，并且把它们演奏出来，那就完全没问题，回去吧。”所以他们从风格上讲，在那个整个时代依然保持着他们对西方偶像（例如“希普·乌里亚”乐队）的喜爱，但配上了他们自己的德语歌词。这招非常管用，以至于他们
were really, really popular, both East and West Germany. They actually played concerts in West Germany as well and became one of the most, the most successful band in the GDR. So they're influenced by Western bands. And that raises a bigger question, which is if you were there in East Berlin or wherever, Karl-Marx-Stadt or in East Germany, I mean, do you get West German TV? Do you get West German radio? Do you get, so are you conscious of everything that's going on or are you living in a little prison not knowing that this is happening?
非常非常受欢迎，在东德和西德都是如此。它们实际上也在西德举办过音乐会，并成为了民主德国最成功、最受欢迎的乐队之一。所以它们受到了西方乐队的影响。这就引出了一个更大的问题：如果你当时身处东柏林、卡尔马克思城或者东德的其他地方，你能看到西德的电视吗？你能收到西德的广播吗？你能——也就是说，你对发生的一切都有所觉察，还是生活在一个小囚笼里，对这一切浑然不知？
Both to some extent. I mean, you get West German TV and radio almost everywhere in the GDR, apart from what was dubbed the Valley of the Clueless in Saxony, where you couldn't get it. Some of my family are from there and they joke that they still live in the Valley of the Clueless. But other than that, it was very possible and very commonly done. Like the authorities themselves reckon that the vast, vast majority of people watch Western TV and listen to Western radio. And to the point, actually, where they adapted their own programming. If there was something, you know, like a crowd pleaser on in the West, they'd kind of make sure that what they wanted people to see wouldn't be on at the same time. Because they knew that people would watch like west german tv so it was commonly known that that was a thing that people did and you were also legally allowed to play and listen to uh western
两者兼而有之，在某种程度上。我的意思是，除了萨克森那个被讽刺为“无知山谷”的地方收不到之外，你在民主德国的几乎所有地方都能看到西德的电视和听到西德的广播。我的一些家人就来自那里，他们开玩笑说自己依然住在“无知山谷”里。但除此之外，这是完全可能做到的，而且也非常普遍。比如，当局自己估计，绝大多数人都在看西方电视、听西方广播。甚至到了这种程度：他们调整了自己的节目编排。如果西方有什么很受欢迎的节目，他们就会确保自己想让民众看的节目不会在同一时间播出。因为他们知道人们会去看西德的电视，所以这是大家都知道的做法，而且你在国内合法地播放和收听西方……
music uh in the country so long as you follow the ratio of 50 to 60 so it had to be 60 music either from east germany or the eastern bloc so it's like france yeah in many ways you could say that but the thing i mean the thing is in the 60s and 70s there is a kind of consumer society developing in in east germany so they have more fridges by what what's the figure um by 1970 56.4 percent of households had a fridge, as against West Germany's 28%. There are holidays. So you have 18 days holiday a year. And famously, you have the Trabant. So tell us about the Trabant, which is kind of the ultimate symbol really of East Germany, isn't it? It is. And it's become a symbol of how decrepit the socialist system is, because people looked at them kind of rolling over the border in 1989
音乐也是可以的，只要你遵循五比六的比例，也就是说音乐中必须有百分之六十来自东德或东欧集团。这就像法国一样，对吧？在许多方面，你可以这么说。但问题是，在二十世纪六十年代和七十年代，东德正在形成一种消费社会。所以他们拥有更多的冰箱——到一九七〇年，具体数字是多少呢？百分之五十六点四的家庭拥有冰箱，而西德这一比例为百分之二十八。还有假期。你一年有十八天的假期。还有一个大名鼎鼎的卫星牌汽车（Trabant）。给我们讲讲卫星牌吧，它可以说是东德的终极象征，对吧？确实如此。它已经成了社会主义制度衰败的象征，因为人们看着它们在一九八九年翻越边境时，
and stinking and smithing. So these are cars made in... Yeah, indeed, like two-stroke, little two-stroke cars, which were terribly outdated really by the end of the GDR in 1989. But when they first introduced them, they were actually quite modern and decent cars. They were sort of modelled on the same design principles as the Triumph Herald in Britain. And they look quite stylish, the early ones, when you look at them.
冒着烟气，散发着恶臭。所以这些车是……是的，确实，就像二冲程汽车，小型的二冲程汽车。到了一九八九年民主德国结束时，这些车实际上已经相当过时了。但当它们刚被推出时，其实是相当现代和像样的汽车。它们的设计理念在某种程度上模仿了英国的凯旋先驱（Triumph Herald）。当你看到早期的那些车时，它们看起来还挺时尚的。
People were quite happy with them. The problem was that they didn't get developed any further. So basically, you ended up with the same car model that people were driving in the 1960s, still kind of pretty much the only affordable model in the 1980s, still on a two-stroke engine, which was just, you know, outdated and just a kind of slightly improved model from the previous one, for which you had to wait a long time, you had to apply for it years in advance. So people looked after these cars and they had them. And I think it's worth pointing out that car ownership is nearly the same in East Germany as it is in many Western countries, on a par with Britain.
人们对它们相当满意。问题在于，它们没有得到进一步的开发。所以基本上，你在八十年代开的仍然是人们在六十年代开的同款车，它基本上还是八十年代唯一买得起的车型，依然使用的是二冲程发动机。这仅仅是一个在前一款车型基础上有轻微改进的版本，而且你必须等很长时间，必须提前好几年申请。因此，人们都很爱护这些车并一直拥有它们。我认为值得指出的是，东德的汽车拥有率几乎与许多西方国家持平，与英国不相上下。
But people just didn't update them. They couldn't because they couldn't get kind of new car models from anywhere. And the regime, I don't think, recognised just how car-loving the German people are on the whole and didn't make that the focus, but focused on other things like fridges. That became the flagship sort of figure that they would constantly trump as well, that they'd temporarily overtake them. And gold medals in the Olympics. And that, yes.
但人们就是不更新它们。他们做不到，因为他们无处获取新的汽车型号。而且我认为，政权并没有意识到德国人民总体上是多么热爱汽车，并没有把这作为重点，而是关注其他事情，比如冰箱。冰箱成为了他们经常吹嘘的旗舰数据，他们甚至会暂时在这些方面超越西方。还有奥运会金牌。是的，还有那些。
So the sporting thing, that kicks in in the late 60s. Is that right? Yeah, from the time really when East Germany gets its own national team. For a while, they had to sort of form one all-German team together with the West Germans, which must have been an interesting diplomatic exercise in itself. But once they've got their own, they're really using that to try and create kind of like a national spirit, if you will. So a lot of time, money and thought goes into how to create the sporting success.
所以体育这块，是从六十年代末开始发力的。是这样吗？是的，确切地说是从东德拥有自己的国家队开始的。有一段时间，他们必须和西德人一起组建一支全德联合队伍，这本身一定是一次有趣的政治外交演练。但一旦他们有了自己的队伍，他们就真的利用这一点来试图建立一种国家精神，如果你这么觉得的话。因此，大量的时间、金钱和心思都投入到了如何创造体育辉煌上。
And so the stereotype is that they're pumping particularly women with steroids. And so you have all these kind of bearded women with huge muscles who are chucking shotputs out of the stadium. Yes, and I mean, they did. Absolutely, they did. And you can really see that in the records that are still there. There is no way of getting around that, especially as they identified that if you give steroids to women early when they're still in their teens, it permanently alters their physique.
所以刻板印象是，他们给女性大量注射类固醇。于是你就会看到所有这些满脸胡须、肌肉发达的女性，把铅球从体育场里扔出去。是的，我的意思是，他们确实这么做了。绝对的，他们这么干了。你从至今依然存在的记录中就能清楚地看到这一点。这是无法回避的，尤其是当他们发现，如果在女性还是十几岁的青少年时期就给她们注射类固醇，这会永久性地改变她们的体格。
So you can kind of temporarily stop giving them the steroids and they will still perform better in the actual competitions than without them. So this happened and it really permanently damaged the female athletes that were involved in these programs. So it's an interesting story, isn't it, with East Germany? Because your book, your pains to sort of say you've got an extraordinary rate of kind of gender equality. So more women working than in most comparable Western countries.
所以你可以暂时停止给她们使用类固醇，在实际比赛中，她们的表现依然会比不用时更好。这确实发生了，并且彻底、永久地损害了参与这些项目的女性运动员。所以，东德是一个有趣的故事，不是吗？因为你的书极力想要表明，你们拥有非同寻常的性别平等率。比如女性就业率比大多数可比的西方国家都要高。
You have the paid holidays, which Tom mentioned. You have the consumer society. And you still have people who are quite idealistic. And yet on the other side of the equation, as it were, you have the regime that is pumping the athletes full of steroids. But you also have, for is pumping the athletes full of steroids but you also have for example the stasi so the image that most of our listeners i guess will have of east germany is a society in which you're being spied on the whole time and it's very repressive i mean i've been to the stasi museum in berlin lots of our listeners probably have where they've got sort
你们有带薪假期，汤姆刚才提到了。你们有消费社会。而且你们还有一群相当理想主义的人。但另一方面，正如我们所看到的，这个政权正在给运动员注射大量类固醇。不仅如此，比如对于类固醇的注射……但与此同时，你也有斯塔西（Stasi）。所以，我想我们大多数听众对东德的印象是一个你时刻被监视、且非常压抑的社会。我的意思是，我去过柏林的斯塔西博物馆，我们的很多听众可能也去过，那里摆放着各种……
of examples of cameras in trees and cameras hidden in i I don't know, cars or something. And everybody is watching everybody else. And do you think that latter image is overstated? So in other words, do you think East Germany was a better place than we commonly think in the West? Or am I now swinging too far to the other extreme? I think it was a more normal place than people think it is rather than better I'd say um it completely literally completely depended on who you were what you made of the state I mean if you were somebody who comes from a working class background and suddenly all those opportunities open up for you you can go to university you get paid while you study you can have children while you study
藏在树里的相机，藏在——我不知道，汽车或其他东西里的相机。每个人都在监视其他人。你认为后一种印象被夸大了吗？换句话说，你认为东德是一个比我们在西方普遍认为的更好的地方吗？还是说我现在摇摆得太厉害，走向了另一个极端？我认为它比人们想象的要更像一个正常的地方，而不是更好。我想说的是，这完全、字面意义上完全取决于你是谁，以及你如何看待这个国家。我的意思是，如果你出身于工人阶级背景，突然之间所有的机会都向你敞开：你可以上大学，学习期间有津贴，你还可以在求学期间生孩子——
like my mum was at university um when when I was born and you know the way that it worked was you would just put in a in a larger room which had a nursery attached to it you could take your child literally up to the lecture room drop them at a child care center there go to the lecture come back out pick them back up that all worked um you know and you kind of never had to worry about the existential things that like western working class people worried about like you know your the stability of your job how much you'd earn from one day to the next could you afford your rent could you afford to to heat your house you know none of that was an issue and if you were happy to live within this kind of relatively small world that the the state set up for you you could do that without
就像我出生时我妈妈正在上大学一样。你知道它的运作方式是，你会被安排在一个较大的房间里，房间附带一个托儿所。你可以把孩子直接带到演讲教室，把他们放在那里的托儿中心，然后去听讲座，回来后再把他们接走。这一切都是行之有效的。你知道的，你永远不必担心西方工人阶级所担心的那些生存问题，比如明天的工作是否稳定、一天能挣多少钱、能不能付得起房租、能不能给房子供暖。这些都不是问题。如果你乐于生活在国家为你建立的这个相对的小世界里，你完全可以做到这一点，而不会感到……
existential fears kind of bearing down on you because all of the basic goods in life were were stabilized and as far as the Stasi goes people just obviously knew that they were being watched and this was something that happened to the vast majority of people they knew that the Stasi was around and watched their lives but for the most part the Stasi didn't really seem to know what it was going to do with the information. I give an example of my dad in the book where he was basically, it was implied that you shouldn't marry my mother because she had Western relatives and he was in a very sensitive area in the army where he dealt with radio signaling, which they didn't want to trust to somebody who had kind of potentially relatives in the West. And, you know, they kind
生存的恐惧压得你喘不过气来，因为生活中所有的基本物资都得到了保障。就斯塔西而言，人们显然知道自己正在被监视，这发生在绝大多数人身上。他们知道斯塔西就在身边并监视着他们的生活，但对大多数人来说，斯塔西似乎并不知道该如何处理这些信息。我在书中举了我父亲的例子，基本上暗示他不应该娶我母亲，因为她有西方亲戚。而他在军队里从事无线电信号传输的敏感岗位，他们不想信任一个在西方可能有潜在亲戚的人。你知道的，他们只是……
of just suggested that to him and kept saying things like did you know that your your parents-in-law had gone to hamburg again over the weekend because they were you know kind of visiting family or something and he he said well of course i do they're my parents-in-law of course i know that they went you know and they just let him know that they knew and he knew that nothing would come of it other than the fact that they wouldn't trust him with sort of really sensitive radio technology um but it was just a part of life and i've asked him you know i don't know how many times like did that not bother you they knew everything about you there's a whole file somewhere that he hasn't even looked at um and doesn't want to look at because he says
向他暗示这一点，并不断说诸如“你知道你的岳父母这周末又去汉堡了吗，因为他们要去探亲之类的”这样的话。他说：“我当然知道，他们是我的岳父母，我当然知道他们去了。”他们只是让他知道他们掌握情况，而他也很清楚除了不能把真正的敏感无线电技术交给他之外，不会有什么别的后果。但这只是生活的一部分。我问过他——不知道问了多少次——“这难道不困扰你吗？他们对你了如指掌，某个地方存着一整卷他甚至没看过、也不想看的档案，因为他说……”
he knows what's in it what's the point you know this is kind of just a fact of life that people dealt with i think because that's the world of Deutschland 83. Brilliant drama about an East German who goes to the West to kind of infiltrate. And I suppose that's the other thing that people in the West would know about East Germany is its kind of outsized role that it plays in spy dramas and all those kind of things. And the idea of the stars he has is incredibly effective. And it's also its foreign mission. So what is it? Markus Wolf? The man without face. The model for Carla in the Carré novels. That in that sense, the impression of East Germany is actually, it's quite an impressive state,
他知道里面写了什么，有什么意义呢？你知道的，这只是人们应对生活的一种现实。我想，这就是电视剧《德国83年》的世界。这是一部关于一名东德人潜入西方的精彩剧集。我想这也是西方人对东德的另一种了解，即它在间谍剧中扮演的超乎寻常的角色以及诸如此类的事情。斯塔西的形象是非常高效的。这也是它的海外使命。那么，他是谁？马库斯·沃尔夫（Markus Wolf）？无面人。约翰·勒卡雷小说中卡拉（Carla）的原型。从这个意义上说，东德给人的印象其实是一个令人印象深刻的国家，
that it's a significant player, a significant actor in the Cold War. But at the same time, the impression I get from your book is that the blue jeans, the fridges almost serves as a kind of sugar rush for people in East Germany. And when that starts to crash, that is a problem for these Germans, because basically they're starting to run out of money. you have this as early as 1977 this this um this crisis in sourcing coffee which is incredibly important eric's brew and muckerfuck which who knows what that means he said that very carefully which is good but it doesn't sound good i mean it's the kind of what is it it's kind of basically dust and shavings chicory apparently i think the basis of it. And it's horrible.
它是冷战中的一个重要玩家、重要的行动者。但与此同时，我从你的书中得到的印象是，牛仔裤、冰箱几乎成了东德人民的一种“糖分冲击”。当这种冲击开始消退时，这就成了东德人的一个问题，因为基本上他们的钱开始不够用了。早在1977年，你就面临着这种采购咖啡的危机，这极其重要——埃里克冲剂（Eric's brew）和代用咖啡（muckerfuck）。谁知道那是什么意思？他刚才非常小心地把这个词说出来了，这很好，但这听起来并不好。我的意思是，这是一种什么东西？基本上就是灰尘和刨花，据我所知，好像是以菊苣为基础的。而且这东西太难喝了。
And reading about the coffee crisis, actually, it sounds quite significant. Coffee, presumably, is quite important. It is. I mean, Germans do like their coffee. Yeah. I mean, and this is something I tried to get that across in the book. This is something that was associated with post-war stability, having coffee ready and available to you at all times.
读到关于咖啡危机的内容时，这其实听起来相当重要。咖啡大概是非常重要的东西吧。确实如此。我的意思是，德国人确实喜欢他们的咖啡。是的。我的意思是，这也是我试图在书中表达的一点。这东西与战后稳定联系在一起，随时随地都有现成的咖啡可以喝。
It's like a little comfort blanket. You know, whatever happens. I suppose it's the equivalent to tea. People say, oh, just put the kettle on and everything will be fine in Britain. I think the equivalent to that in Germany is coffee, I think. And when that wasn't available, just imagine tea wasn't available in Britain. People would freak out.
这就像一条小毛毯，能带来慰藉。无论发生什么。我想这就相当于英国的茶。人们会说：“哦，烧个水泡壶茶，英国的一切都会好起来的。”我认为德国与此对等的东西就是咖啡。当咖啡买不到时——想象一下如果英国买不到茶，人们会抓狂的。
And it's the same sort of thing, I think, in the regime notice system. Is that a canary in the mine? So in the 80s, is there a sense that the economy in East Germany is starting to run down relative to the West? And are East Germans becoming resentful of that? Yeah, I mean, their problem is that they're trying to create a socialist society. So basically a society where everyone has enough of everything, but nothing luxurious or kind of on top of that.
我想这在政权感知系统里也是一样的情况。这算不算是矿井里的金丝雀（预警信号）？所以在八十年代，人们是否觉得东德的经济相对于西方开始走下坡路了？东德人是否开始对此感到怨恨？是的，我的意思是，他们的问题在于他们试图建立一个社会主义社会。基本上就是一个每个人都有足够的一切，但没有奢侈品或额外东西的社会。
So you have things like rent, food, holidays, all of those kinds of basic things are all subsidized to a point where they are very, very easily affordable and people still have lots of money left over to do things. And then they can't buy anything with that money. So that was, you know, they look at their Western relatives and the Western relatives don't tell them that they're struggling to pay the rent next month, but they're wearing a pair of jeans, you know. And so I think you get a very, very slanted image in East Germany as to what the West is like, because you view it through this very narrow lens of Western television. And Honegger is trying to do both. He's trying to keep this welfare state that people are used to, which is incredibly expensive. You know, free education as well, all the way through to university, all of that's happening. If you're an adult and your employer looks at you and thinks, actually, you're a bit too clever for the position that you're doing.
所以你拥有房租、食物、假期之类的一切。所有这些基本的东西都被补贴到一个非常、非常容易负担的程度，人们手里还剩很多钱可以做别的事。然后他们发现用这些钱却买不到任何东西。所以你知道的，他们看着自己的西方亲戚，西方亲戚虽然不会告诉他们下个月付房租有多艰难，但他们身上穿着一条牛仔裤。所以，我认为你在东德会对西方是什么样有一个非常、非常偏颇的印象，因为你是通过西方电视这个非常狭窄的镜头来观察它的。昂纳克（Honecker）试图两面兼顾。他试图维持人们习以为常的福利国家体制，而这极其昂贵。你知道的，还有免费教育，一直到大学，所有这些都在继续。如果你是一个成年人，你的雇主看着你，觉得实际上你比你当前岗位所要求的人才要聪明一点，
Don't you want to do something else? They can send you back to university, even at an adult age, and you're getting that paid for. So all of that's happening, and at the same time, Honecker is now trying to give people TVs, colour TVs and radios and later Walkmans in the 80s and all of those stereo things for people to have at home, all of these things that in the West only a small portion of the population can actually afford.
难道你不想做点别的吗？他们可以把你送回大学，哪怕你已经是成年人了，而且这些费用都是由国家支付的。所以所有这些都在发生，与此同时，昂纳克现在正试图给人们提供电视、彩色电视和收音机，以及后来的八十年代的随身听和各种立体声音响，让人们放在家里享受。所有这些东西，在西方也只有一小部分人口真正负担得起。
But it looks to people, because they see the adverts and they listen to their relatives in the West, it looks to people, because they see the adverts and they listen to their relatives in the West, it looks to people as though everybody has it. And you can't have both of these things by definition. You can't have a society that's got everything for everyone and then luxury on top of that for everyone as well. That just doesn't work economically. And Honecker overstretches himself massively, and they find that out in the 1980s. But even at that point in the 80s, so when they've cheap oil deliveries on which they've relied from the Soviet Union have been cut, they're running into massive economic problems. East Germany has at this point existed for about 35 years.
但由于人们看到了广告，听到了西方亲戚的讲述，在人们看来——由于他们看到了广告，听到了西方亲戚的讲述——在人们看来，仿佛每个人都拥有这些东西。从逻辑上讲，你不可能两全其美。你不可能拥有一个既能为所有人提供一切、又能为所有人提供额外奢侈品的社会。从经济学角度来看，这是行不通的。昂纳克极大地透支了自己，他们在一九八〇年代意识到了这一点。但即便在八十年代的那个时候，当他们一直依赖的来自苏联的廉价石油供应被切断时，他们正陷入巨大的经济危机。东德到此时已经存在了大约三十五年之久。
So it's looking forward to its 40th anniversary. There are an awful lot of people who are now alive who have known nothing but East Germany. You were four in that story that Tom told, but there are lots of people who would have been older than you who were at school who take East Germany for granted. And the regime is also creating, I mean, one of the things I find fascinating is they're creating a separate East German historic identity based on Martin Luther and on Prussia and on a sort of separate history. So is there a point there in the 1980s where most people genuinely believe East Germany is its own thing? It's not just some sort of mutilated appendix of a greater Germany, but it's its own thing with its own history, its own culture, and it will last for generations. about 1989, there's a tiny minority who say now that they knew that the state was going to collapse and Germany was going to reunify. But the vast majority of people thought there were two German states for the foreseeable future. And you see that even in the conversations between the West German Chancellor Helmut Kohl and Erich Honecker, that they're working towards kind of what they call
所以它正期盼着自己的四十周年庆典。现在有大量活着的人只知道东德。汤姆讲那个故事时你才四岁，但有很多人比你年长，他们在学校里把东德视为理所当然。这个政权还在创造——我的意思是，我发现最迷人的一件事情是，他们正在以马丁·路德、普鲁士和一种独特的历史为基础，创造一个独立的东德历史认同。那么在八十年代的某个时刻，大多数人是否真的相信东德有它自己独立的东西？它不仅仅是一个大德国被肢解的阑尾，而是一个拥有自身历史、自身文化、并将延续数代人的独立实体？关于一九八九年，只有极少数人现在声称他们当时就知道国家会崩溃、德国会重新统一。但绝大多数人在可预见的未来都认为存在两个德国。你甚至可以从西德总理赫尔穆特·科尔（Helmut Kohl）和埃里克·昂纳克之间的对话中看出这一点，他们正朝着所谓的
a neighbourly relationship between the two states, because they both accept at this point that for the foreseeable future, there will be two German states. East Germany has got its own citizenship, for example. There is through sport to some extent as well, a kind of East German identity on the world stage. You've got your own team, basically, that you look up to. So I think there was certainly a sense that maybe it was still one nation, but it would live in two separate states for now. I mean, Katja, the transcripts of the dialogue between Eric Honecker and Chancellor Kohl of West Germany, and you reproduce some of it. I mean, it's magnificent. So Honecker phoning up Kohl. Yes. Hello.? Yes. And Cole saying, yes, this is Cole. Good day.
两国之间的睦邻关系努力，因为他们在这个时候都接受了在可预见的未来将存在两个德国的事实。例如，东德拥有自己的公民身份。在世界舞台上，某种程度上也通过体育运动形成了一种东德身份认同。基本上，你们有自己的队伍可以仰慕。所以我想，肯定有一种感觉：也许它仍然是一个国家，但目前它将生活在两个不同的政权中。卡佳，埃里克·昂纳克和西德总理科尔之间的对话记录——你引用了其中一部分。我的意思是，这太棒了。所以昂纳克给科尔打电话。是的。喂？是的。科尔说，是的，我是科尔。你好。
Good day, Chancellor. This is Honika. Yes, good day, General Secretary. How are you? Excellent, I would like to say. If only the weather was a little better. How is the weather over there? Misty?
你好，总理阁下。我是昂纳克。是的，你好，总书记先生。你好吗？好极了，我想这么说。要是天气再好一点就好了。那边天气怎么样？有雾吗？
Fog? I mean, this is almost British level conversation. I mean, it's quite interesting. So, it all seems so normal yeah that's exactly it that's what i was trying to get to with that is that it was just normal and i mean call obviously once he gets a chance in 1989 styles himself as the unification chancellor but he certainly had a fairly you know workable amicable relationship with with honeger you suppose when they when they first met in moscow at andropos funeral the first time and then then for their first former meeting at chanenkos but
雾？我的意思是，这几乎是英国水平的对话。我的意思是，这挺有趣的。所以，这一切看起来都那么正常，是的，这正是重点，这就是我试图表达的，它只是正常。当然，我的意思是，一旦他在1989年抓住机会，将自己塑造为统一的联邦总理，但他与昂纳克确实保持着相当（你知道的）可行且友好的关系。你猜想，当他们在莫斯科安德罗波夫的葬礼上第一次见面，然后又在切尔年科的葬礼上进行第一次正式会面时，
the first time they met he's supposed to have said to him you know if we speak in dialect and people won't understand what we're saying you can't be eavesdropped upon because their birthplaces are only 100 kilometers apart which is quite remarkable you know so they they do have this unlikely sort of relatively personal relationship with one another where there is, I think, a degree of goodwill on both sides to try and make this work. So 1989 comes and the description you gave, which I read so beautifully, impersonating you at the beginning of this. It's like I was here. It really is. It really is. Tell us what happens. So first of all, what happens when your father sees this? What happens to you? What's the process? And then how do you fit that into the broader context of because it was 1989. It was the last day of the Republic, the 7th of October,
他们第一次见面时，据说他对他说，你知道的，如果我们说方言，人们就不会明白我们在说什么，这样你就不会被窃听，因为他们的出生地相距只有100公里，这非常了不起，你知道的。所以他们确实有这种不太可能的、相对个人的关系，双方都在一定程度上怀有善意，试图让事情行得通。因此，1989年来了，你给出的那个描述，我开头模仿你，读得那么优美。就好像我当时就在现场一样。真的是这样。真的是这样。告诉我们发生了什么。首先，当你父亲看到这一切时，发生了什么？你身上发生了什么？过程是怎样的？然后，你如何将它融入更广泛的背景中，因为那是1989年。那是共和国的最后一天，10月7日，
which was a nice sunny day because it was the day of the Republic. Everybody had the day off and most families like my own used it to just have a day out. So we chose to go to Berlin and go up the TV tower, which was perhaps bad timing because that's when there was a huge ceremony in Berlin to try and sort of celebrate the last day of the Republic. Gorbachev had come along to witness it. And as a result of that, you get mass demonstrations against that at the same time.
那是个晴朗的好日子，因为那是共和国日。每个人都放假了，大多数家庭就像我家一样，利用这个假期出去游玩。所以我们选择去柏林，登上电视塔，这或许是个糟糕的时机，因为那是柏林举行盛大庆典、试图庆祝共和国最后一天的时刻。戈尔巴乔夫也出席了见证。因此，与此同时，你也看到了大规模的抗议示威。
And there was no telling whatsoever what the police would do or the security forces would do because the authorities were still talking about a Chinese solution to this, meaning the massacre that had happened on Tiamat in square. And they're still kind of at least threatening to dangle that into the air, that threat. Katja, why the demonstrations? And the reason I ask why is because surely at that point, most people in East Germany are better off than they have ever been. So much as we look at it from the viewpoint of 2023 and we say, what a ghastly regime, what a terrible place, even though you've made your case about its normality,
当时根本无法预料警察或安全部队会采取什么行动，因为当局仍在谈论“中国式的解决方案”，意思是在天安门广场发生的屠杀。他们仍然至少在威胁要把这种威胁悬在空中。卡娅，为什么要示威？我问“为什么”的原因是，在那个时候，东德绝大多数人的生活肯定比以往任何时候都要好。尽管我们从2023年的角度来看待它，认为这是一个多么可怕的政权、多么糟糕的地方，尽管你已经证明了它的正常性，
it's not like they're suddenly terribly badly off. It's not like the regime has suddenly become loads more repressive than it was before. What's driving people out onto the streets? I think that's part of the problem is they put people in a position where they are incredibly well-educated. Germany is one of the most widely read societies in the world at that point. People read a lot. People are very intelligent because they've been basically well-educated to a much like they all take the same schooling to year 10, which is kind of really high quality and there
但并不是说他们突然陷入了极度困境。并不是说这个政权突然变得比以前严厉得多。是什么驱使人们走上街头？我认为这正是问题的一部分，他们把人们置于这样一种境地：他们受过极好的教育。当时的德国是世界上人读书最多的社会之一。人们读很多书。人们非常聪明，因为他们基本上受过良好的教育，就像所有人都要接受到10年级的相同教育一样，这种教育质量真的很高，而且
is no streaming as such. So you've got a very well-educated, highly politicized, quite comfortable population and confident population who are now saying, why isn't this changing? Why can't we have reform? Why can't we get a say? And this is very, very different from the early years where people just wanted peace, stability, and wanted to basically just get on with their lives regardless of what was happening at the top.
没有什么分流机制。所以你拥有一个受过良好教育、高度政治化、生活相当舒适且自信的人群，他们现在在问：为什么没有改变？为什么我们不能进行改革？为什么我们不能有发言权？这与早期人们只想要和平、稳定、不管高层发生什么只想过好自己日子的时期非常非常不同。
People accept a high degree of kind of authoritarianism in the West as well under Conrad Adenauer to start with. And then you see that developing into protests in the late 60s and early 70s for similar reasons. And nothing changes at the top. There's no attempt whatsoever to listen to people, to try and bring reforms in. Honecker is at that point quite old and also getting ill. So he's increasingly even less likely than he had been to start with
人们在康拉德·阿登纳统治之初，在西方也接受了高度的威权主义。然后你会看到，出于类似的原因，这种情况在60年代末和70年代初演变成抗议活动。而高层没有任何改变。没有任何试图倾听民众意见、试图引入改革的企图。昂纳克当时已经相当老了，而且也开始生病。所以他越来越不可能像最初那样
to engage with people and to engage with their arguments. And this is really quite upsetting to a lot of people. I spoke to one man, Wolfgang Walensky, who stood for the Liberal Party in 1989 in the local elections. And they always had to have like a sort of pre-election discussion with the electorate. And he said it was so hostile. People were just sitting there, even though he wasn't actually part of the ruling Socialist Party, but they were sitting there and saying,
去与民众接触，去倾听他们的论点。这确实让很多人感到沮丧。我采访过一个人，沃尔夫冈·瓦伦斯基，他在1989年的地方选举中代表自由党参选。他们总是不得不与选民进行某种形式的选举前讨论。他说当时的敌意太大了。人们就坐在那里，尽管他实际上并不属于执政的社会主义党，但他们坐在那里说：
look, we need change. We need reform. We need to do something about the environment. There still isn't enough housing. Why aren't there enough consumer goods on the shelves? Why can't we have more rights? Why can't you introduce a degree of just trust us? This is kind of the saying that, or the kind of phrase that came out of it. And he said he didn't have any answers because he was
听着，我们需要改变。我们需要改革。我们需要对环境做点什么。住房仍然不够。为什么货架上的消费品不够？为什么我们不能拥有更多的权利？为什么你们不能引入一点“相信我们”的信任度？这就是从中产生的那种说法，或者说那种短语。他说他没有任何答案，因为他在
trying to perform things in his own political party, but didn't get a say himself either, and felt pretty helpless. And that's something that many people, moderate people that I spoke to who could sort of live in the GDR, said that they failed in 1989. So there's the demonstrations. There's also the issue about people literally leaving the country. So people have been leaving through Hungary. Hungary has opened its borders to Austria. So you've got a flight of people.
自己的政党里试图推动事情，但自己也没有发言权，并感到非常无助。这也是我采访过的许多可以生活在民主德国的温和派人士所说的话，他们认为自己在1989年失败了。所以有了示威活动。还有一个问题是人们真的在离开这个国家。所以人们一直在通过匈牙利离开。匈牙利已经向奥地利开放了边界。所以出现了一股逃亡潮。
And in this sort of shambolic moment, they decide they're going to open the border. And they're going to do it in a sort of slightly staggered way. But the spokesman gets it wrong famously and says, it's open right now, and everybody piles across. So it's a similar question to the last one about demonstrations. So okay, they've opened the border and great sort of torrents of people pouring into West Berlin and looking goggle-eyed at the neon signs. And I mean, that's those sort of stereotypical images and stories that we've all heard. But why does the regime then collapse so quickly? So in other words, you make this point, which I think, again, is really counterintuitive and fascinating, that most people at that stage don't want East Germany to end.
在这个混乱的时刻，他们决定开放边境。他们打算以一种稍微错开的方式来做这件事。但发言人出了名地搞错了，说“现在就开放”，然后所有人都蜂拥而过。所以这跟关于示威的最后一个问题类似：好吧，他们开放了边境，大量的人流涌入西柏林，瞪大眼睛看着霓虹灯。我的意思是，那是我们都听过的那些刻板印象的图像和故事。但是，为什么这个政权会这么快崩溃呢？换句话说，你提出了一个观点，我认为这同样非常反直觉且引人入胜，即在那个阶段，大多数人不希望东德结束。
They've got a stake in their own society. They believe in it. There are people publishing open letters, famous writers like Christoph Wolff saying, you know, we've built something, let's not throw it away. Why do they throw it away? Yeah, it's an interesting question that because you do get like really existential fears from a lot of people as well. When, you know, I spoke to people, I heard everything from, you know, finally, I could go and travel west and see my relatives. But really, I just wanted to carry on with my life, you know, if the border had just been open um but of course one problem is that once that border is open you know
他们在自己的社会中有着切身利益。他们信仰它。有人在发表公开信，像克里斯托夫·沃尔夫这样著名的作家说，你知道的，我们已经建立了一些东西，不要把它扔掉。为什么他们把它扔掉了？是的，这是一个有趣的问题，因为你确实也从很多人那里得到了真正的生存恐惧。当（你知道的）我与人们交谈时，我听到了一切，从“终于我可以去西方旅行并看望我的亲戚了”，但实际上，如果边境刚刚被开放，我只是想继续我的生活，你知道的。但当然，一个问题是，一旦边境被开放，你知道的，
when we when we talked about the berlin wall earlier it was there for a reason and it reopened literally the same problem again and that people would have migrated westwards very quickly and they did actually this happens even in the 90s east germany pretty much empties out where i grew up in rural brandenburg just outside of ber, people used to joke that they turned the whole thing into a nature reserve now because there were only five people left in it. So that is a problem that would have continued. So it would have created an existential crisis economically for the GDR in any case. And on top of that, you've got Helmut Kohl, who now sees his own chance to get out. He was in a lot of political trouble in West Germany at the time. His government was looking like it was going
当我们之前谈到柏林墙时，它在那里是有原因的，它实际上重新引发了同样的问题，即人们会非常迅速地向西迁移，他们确实这样做了。实际上，甚至在90年代也是如此，东德几乎空无一人。在我长大的柏林郊外的勃兰登堡乡村，人们曾经开玩笑说，他们现在把整个地方都变成了一个自然保护区，因为里面只剩下五个人了。所以这是一个会持续下去的问题。无论如何，这都会给民主德国带来经济上的生存危机。除此之外，还有赫尔穆特·科尔，他现在看到了自己脱颖而出的机会。他当时在西德遇到了很大的政治麻烦，他的政府看起来要
to lose the next election. And so he seizes this chance and makes this his moment, comes to East Germany and basically says to people, you know, you're going to live in a free society. You're going to have all of the things that you've always wanted. And we're going create a state don't worry about unemployment we'll sort this out there will be state support for this and i think over promised a lot as well this is what leads to a lot of the dissatisfaction i think in the 1990s and early 2000s um when a fifth of the east german working population is unemployed but basically kohl said this wasn't going to happen so to many people it looked like certainly you know when you get into the spring of 1990 it looked like why would you hold on to this old state that was so calcified and wouldn't change when you can join the state that we've viewed through like television adverts and tv shows and our western relatives for so long
在下次选举中失败。因此，他抓住了这个机会，将这作为他的高光时刻，来到东德，基本上对人们说，你知道的，你们将生活在一个自由的社会中。你们将拥有你们一直想要的一切。我们将建立一个国家，不用担心失业，我们会解决这个问题，会有国家对此提供支持。而且我认为他也承诺得太多了，这导致了我认为在20世纪90年代和2000年代初的许多不满，当时五分之一的东德劳动人口失业，但基本上科尔说这不会发生。因此，对许多人来说，这看起来——当然，当你进入1990年春天时——看起来为什么你要抓着这个如此钙化且不愿改变的旧国家不放，而你可以加入这个我们通过电视广告、电视节目以及我们的西方亲戚长期以来一直视其为
as this kind of western utopia and and looking at it back at it now, it's vanished, it's gone. Do you think it has left a long-term legacy? Will the experiences of the fact that a portion of Germany was a separate country for as long as it was, do you think it will permanently mark Germany or will the waters close over it completely? I think it will for some time. I mean, when you think about the society that
西方乌托邦的国家呢？现在回过头来看，它已经消失了，不见了。你认为它留下了长期的遗留影响吗？德国的一部分曾作为一个独立国家存在了那么久，这段经历会永远在德国留下印记，还是会彻底烟消云散？我认为它会在一段时间内留下印记。我的意思是，当你想到他们
they created, it was a completely different one from West Germany. And you still see that now in any statistic that you look at, you know, you can look at anything from voting patterns to vaccine acceptance, attitudes towards Russia, how much wine people drink, how young their parents are, old their parents, anything that you look at statistically, you put that onto a map of Germany and you see the old border reappearing, which I find fascinating. It's like the sort of after image, you blink and it just doesn't go away. I grew up with both of my parents in full-time employment. It was perfectly normal for me to walk out of my primary school at midday with a key in my hand and walk home and just cook my own dinner and get on with things that
创造的社会时，它与西德完全不同。你现在看任何统计数据，依然能看到这一点，你知道的，你可以看任何数据，从投票模式到疫苗接受度、对俄罗斯的态度、人们喝多少酒、他们的父母有多年轻或多老，你在统计数据中看到的任何东西，把它叠加到德国地图上，你都会看到旧的边境重新出现，我觉得这太迷人了。这就像是一种视觉后像，你眨眨眼，它就是不消失。我和双职工夫父母一起长大。我中午放学回家，手里拿着钥匙，走回家自己做晚饭，然后做事情，这对我来说是完全正常的。这
would never have occurred to most west german mothers to to sort of do that you know at the age of like seven eight nine to allow their children to do that it leaves a legacy it leaves a cultural and a and a so i think like a sort of sociological legacy to some extent as well as a wider society has changed and people individually have changed i think and they pass that on so east germans want to still get their children earlier than west germans because they're they're used to that from their own um background it's economically more difficult now to do that but many still aim to have their children say in their in their sort of mid-20s rather than in their 30s um which which is happening in in what was western germany so those may all seem small points, but they're still there and they will,
在大多数西德母亲看来是绝对不会想到的（你知道的）在七、八、九岁的时候允许他们的孩子这样做。它留下了遗留影响，它在某种程度上留下了文化上的以及（我认为）社会学上的遗留影响，更广泛的社会已经改变了，我认为个人也改变了，并且他们将这一点传递下去了。所以东德人仍然希望比西德人更早生孩子，因为他们习惯了自己（嗯）背景中的那种生活。现在在经济上要做到这一点更困难了，但许多人仍然把目标定在20岁左右生孩子，而不是像现在西德地区那样在30多岁生孩子。这些看起来可能都是小点，但它们依然存在，并且它们将
I think, perpetuate for a while longer. And do you personally ever feel East German? Yes, in those cultural senses I just talked about. So it's things like East Germans, for instance, are more likely to shake hands with people when they meet them. So you come into a room, you stick your hand out and everyone just looks at you. You know, we don't do this. And this is even before COVID, you know, people in West Germany would just sort of wave their hand and say hello into a room whilst you introduce yourself and do that. Or you take your shoes off. It's an East German thing when you go into somebody's flat or house before you go in.
我认为，会持续更长时间。你自己曾经觉得自己是东德人吗？是的，在刚才我谈到的那些文化意义上。所以这是诸如东德人在见面时更有可能与人握手之类的事情。所以你走进一个房间，你伸出手，每个人都看着你。你知道的，“我们不这样”。甚至在新冠疫情之前，西德的人们也只是在房间里挥挥手打个招呼，同时自我介绍并这样做。或者你脱鞋。当你走进某人的公寓或房子，在进去之前，脱鞋是一件很东德的事。这
And again, that's not something that West Germans tend to do. They tend to sort of just wipe them and then go in and then wait to be asked whether to take them off or keep them on. It's little things like this. So what you're basically saying is West Germans are unfriendly and unhygienic. You heard it here. I wouldn't go quite that far, but... Yeah, I mean, that's what you said. Listen, you can't throw back from that now. Well, Katja, thanks so much. And your book, Beyond the Wall, East Germany, 1949 to 1990, is out now.
也是西德人通常不会做的事。他们往往只是擦擦鞋然后进去，然后等待别人要求他们脱鞋还是留着鞋。就是这样的小事。所以你基本上是在说西德人不友好而且不卫生？你在这里听到了。我不会走得那么远，但是……是的，我的意思是，这就是你说的。听着，你现在可收不回去了。好吧，卡娅，非常感谢。你的新书《Beyond the Wall, East Germany, 1949 to 1990》（墙那边：东德，1949-1990）现已出版。
Fascinating. I mean, really fascinating. Book about something that I turned out I didn't know anything about at all, but I thought I vaguely did. So thanks so much. Yeah, thank you, Katja. Auf Wiedersehen, everybody. Tschüss.
太迷人了。我的意思是，真的非常迷人。这本书讲的是一些我以为自己略知一二、但结果却一无所知的事情。所以非常感谢。是的，谢谢你，卡娅。大家再见，Tschüss。
Tschüss. Tschüss. Cheers. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our
Tschüss. Tschüss. 再见。感谢收听《The Rest Is History》。如需收听独家分集、提前收听、无广告收听以及访问我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。那是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《The Rest Is Entertainment》。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、少许八卦。而在我们的
Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家分集以及提前获得现场门票的机会，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。